RIGHT GOOD- GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE- PRESENT BOTH AND
VIRTUALLY AND TO THOSE WHO WILL
BE SPEAKING LATER- THIS IS THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON
CALIFORNIA'S LET HIM BE KANEMI
AND THAT BEFORE WE GET. THE
KIND OF. WE ARE. WE'RE GOING TO
DO SOME HOUSEKEEPING- MATTERS
BEFORE WE GET INTO THE ACTUAL
SUBSTANCE OF THE AGENDA SAW
BEGIN BY SHARING INFORMATION
ABOUT THE STEPS WE'RE TAKING
TO. ENSURE EVERYONE SAFETY HERE
IN THE PUBLIC ALSO HAS ACCESS
TO OUR DISCUSSION TODAY. DUE TO
THE ONGOING PANDEMIC WE ARE
LIMITING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN BE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO ENSURE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. AND MEDIA HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS PROCEEDING WE
ARE ENSURING THAT THERE ARE
MULTIPLE WAYS TO OBSERVE. AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING.
TESTIMONY CAN BE PROVIDED IN
PERSON VIA THE PHONE OR VIA
VIDEO CONFERENCE IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN OF THE CAPITAL. OR
ANY REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION IN
CAPITOL PARK. IT WOULDN'T
CAPITAL MUST WEAR MASKS THIS
INCLUDES. ALL OF US HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. AT ALONG WITH
WITNESSES A VIDEO CONFERENCE-
ROOM. AND- ANYONE
PARTICIPATING. SIMILARLY
EVERYONE PARTICIPATING HEARING
ROOM OR REMOTE TESTIMONY
LOCATIONS AS REQUIRED TO
PRACTICE THE SOCIAL DISTANCE.
RULES OF THE HOUSE. FOR ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC PRESIDENT
HERE ROOM WE ARE REQUIRING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PLEASE
FOLLOW DIRECTIONS OR SERGEANTS
AND ANY POSTED GUIDANCE. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM IS ON THE AGENDA TO
TESTIFY I WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT. SECTION OF THE AGENDA
I WILL ASK. YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE WITH
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO ALSO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
WHEN LEAVING THE CAPITOL FOR
WITNESSES. IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM IN ADDITION TO
TESTIFYING FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE MAY HAVE SOME
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. MAKE USE
OF THE VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOMS
OR THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM IS- FOR THIS
HEARING IS LOCATED IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN. THOSE WITNESSES
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREENS IN
THE ROOM SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIFE AND ASK
QUESTIONS. OF THESE WITNESSES
FOR THOSE WHO WILL BE DOING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. I
WILL ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANYONE CAN PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
AGENDA. THE CALLING NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE PIN. IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. PLEASE CALL
WHEN YOU HAVE HEARD FROM THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. RECALLING
AND PLEASE BE SURE. TO LEMONADE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS
INCLUDES MEETING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCASTS AND ALL YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE. SOUND
ISSUES. YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATOR PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE SELECT
COMMITTEE. AT NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO FIVE
SIX. AND OFFICE STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO HELP FOR THE MEMBERS
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE. MANY
MEMBERS IF YOU'D LIKE TO ASK
QUESTION A PRIVATE COMMENT
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND GET MY
ATTENTION. AND THE MICROPHONE
WILL BE- LET UP FOR YOU TO
SPEAK. BEFORE WE BEGIN. I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO THE COMMITTEE
AND AUDIT COMMITTEE FLOOR. AND
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
VOICES ARE HEARD. OR CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING. IS
PROHIBITED. AND SUCH CONDUCT
MAY BE INCLUDE REMOVING MASS
REFUSING TO PUT IT BACK ON
TALKING OR MAKING LOUD NOISES
FROM THE AUDIENCE. UTTERING
LOUD THREATENING OR ABUSIVE
LANGUAGE SPEAKING LONGER THAN
TIME ALLOTTED EXTENDED
DISCUSSION. OF MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT WHERE
THE HEARING OTHER ACTIONS.
CONSIDERED DISRUPTIVE MAY BE-
WE MAY TAKE AN ACTION IF
INDIVIDUAL- DOES NOT FOLLOW
THESE INSTRUCTIONS. WE WILL
DIRECT THE SERGEANTS TO REMOVE
THESE INDIVIDUALS FROM- THE
HEARING. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CALL COOPERATION IN ADVANCE-
I'LL BEGIN BY JUST SOME FEW
OPEN REMARKS I ASKED ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO WANT TO. SAY A
FEW WORDS AS WELL. THE ABOUT
OVER THE LOGISTICS NOW I WANT
TO WELCOME OUR WITNESSES AND
THANK THEM FOR COMING BEFORE
THE SELECT COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE
US WITH PERSPECTIVES. ON
FINANCING OPPORTUNITIES AND
CHALLENGES IN BUILDING
CALIFORNIA'S BETTER SUPPLY
CHAIN. ALL THE SEED YOU'LL TURN
RESOURCE AREA SATISFY OF GLOBAL
LITHIUM DEMAND ACCORDING TO
INDUSTRY EXPERTS. GOVERNING
SOME ANNOUNCED THAT GASOLINE
POWERED CARS WILL NEED TO BE
PHASED OUT BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE IN THE MAJORITY OF
AUTOMAKERS FROM HYUNDAI TO GM
TO JAGUAR PLANNING ON GOING
ELECTRIC BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
THIS OPPORTUNITY IS EVIDENT.
FOR CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA
BEING ON A PATH. TO BEING BE
GLOBAL EPICENTER OF A CLEAN AND
COMPETITIVE BATTERY
MANUFACTURING SUPPLY CHAIN. THE
LINES WITH THE STATE'S GOALS.
FOR A JUST TRANSITION IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION AND- EVEN- WITH
AN EMPHASIS ON OUR ENERGY
SYSTEM WITH POTENTIAL INFLUX OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS. AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND PRIVATE CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT WE INSURE. RESIDENTS
BUSINESSES AROUND SALT C. FULLY
BENEFIT FROM THESE ENORMOUS
OPPORTUNITIES. AS WELL AS THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
RIGHT FINANCING WILL BE
CRITICAL IN BUILDING SUCCESSFUL
DID LEAVE HIM BATTERY
MANUFACTURING SUPPLY CHAIN.
RIGHT HERE IN OUR OWN BACKYARD.
IN ADDITION FOR CALIFORNIA TO
MEET THE GROWING DEMAND OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE AND GRID
STORAGE MARKETS AND THAT
NATIONAL SECURITY REQUIREMENTS.
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL NEED TO WORK
HAND IN HAND. WITH THAT THIS
HEARING IS DESIGNED TO START
LAYING THE FOUNDATION FOR A
STRATEGIC. LET HIM ACTION PLAN
WHICH COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL
OVERSEE THANK YOU AGAIN TO
EVERYONE WHO IS HERE AND THOSE
WILL BE PARTICIPATING
VIRTUALLY. THIS TIME I'D LIKE
TO OPEN IT UP TO ANY MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO SAY- ANY ANY.
WORDS OR COMMENTS. SURE WELL
THANK YOU- CHAIR I AM QUITE
HONORED AND PROUD TO BE A
MEMBER OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE.
EARLIER THIS YEAR IN THE CITY
OF MORE ON WHICH IS WHERE I
GREW UP IT'S A BORAX MINING
TOWN. LOCATED IN MY DISTRICT-
REAL GENTLE WHICH USED TO BE U.
S. BORAX. HAS ALREADY BEGAN
PRODUCTION OF BATTERY GRADE
LITHIUM. LITHIUM IS EXTRACTED
FROM WASTE ROCK- THE WASTE
WATER PRODUCT FROM NINETY YEARS
OF MINING OF OPERATION AT THIS
PARTICULAR SITE IN MY HOMETOWN.
THE PLANT IS CURRENTLY
OPERATING AT FIVE METRIC TONS A
YEAR. WHICH IS ENOUGH TO
PRODUCE BATTERIES FOR
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY THOUSAND
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. HOWEVER THIS
PLANT HAS THE CAPACITY TO
DOUBLE THAT PRODUCTION
DETAINMENT METRIC TONS OF
BATTERY GRADE LITHIUM A YEAR.
WHICH WOULD POWER A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. I'D LIKE TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THIS PLANT IN BORON IS
PRODUCING LITHIUM ENTIRELY FROM
WASTE MATERIAL WHICH MEANS NO
FURTHER MINING AS NECESSARY.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY CRITICAL OF
THIS GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THE NATION AND THE REST OF THE
WORLD IS SERIOUS ABOUT CARBON
REDUCTION. MY DISTRICT IS
ALREADY TAKEN THE INITIATIVE TO
EXPLORE THIS VALUABLE RESOURCE
TO HELP. SUPPLY THE GROWING
DEMAND FOR LITHIUM BATTERIES
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
IN THE SPEAKER FOR POINTING ME
TO THE SELECT COMMITTEE AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO BEING A
CONTRIBUTOR TO THIS NEW GREEN
ECONOMY. THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU OF CARE GARCIA FOR THIS I'M
HONORED TO BE ON THE COMMITTEE
AS WAS SPOKEN EARLIER I DO HAVE
A LIFT YOUR MIND ON THE FAR
EASTERN EDGES OF MY DISTRICT
AND SHOSHONE VALLEY JUST BEFORE
YOU CROSS OVER NEVADA LOOK
FORWARD TO ALL OF US WORKING
TOGETHER TO BRING THEM ALL
TOGETHER FOR LITHIUM. TO BE
BATTERIES BUT THEN I'LL BRING
IT UP LATER ON IS ONE CONCERN
IS WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO WITH
THE BATTERIES AND FIVE YEARS
AFTER THEY WERE MADE TO BE
RECYCLED OR IN THE WAY SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION
AND GO FOR THE SPEAKERS ARE
GOING TO GO FORWARD. AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THEY YOU BUT TO
BE FOR A PARTICIPATING TODAY'S
HEARING THE FIRST A PANEL WILL
BE. MADE UP OF COMMISSIONER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION THAT'S KAREN DOUGLAS
YOU'LL- GIVE US A BIT OF A SOME
CONTEXT IN TERMS OF- PRIOR
HEARING. AND HOW IT FITS INTO
TODAY'S DISCUSSION SO FAR
KAREN. A COMMISSIONER KAREN
DOUGLAS IS WITH US I THINK
SHE'S GOT ABOUT FIVE MINUTES TO
GIVE A PRESENTATION AND SHE-
ALL. I'M THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M HERE I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY IN THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK HERE TODAY
AND TO HELP SET THE STAGE FOR
THIS DISCUSSION TODAY- MY
COMMENTS ARE GOING TO FOCUS ON
THE US ALL SEE AREA BUT I DID
WANT TO MENTION I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE CHAIR OF
THE COMMISSION TO VISIT THE
MINDED AND MORE ON WHERE OF
MINE TAILINGS ARE BEING PROCESS
TO EXTRACT LITHIUM AND IT'S
ANOTHER EXCITING EXAMPLE OF
CALIFORNIA'S. LITHIUM OF
POTENTIAL AS AS WE CONSIDER THE
LITHIUM ECONOMY EACH YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA- SO WHAT I'M GOING
TO FOCUS ON IS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO RECOVER LITHIUM FROM
GEOTHERMAL BRINES AT THE SALTON
SEA AND HOW THAT DIFFERS FROM
SOME OF THE MORE TRADITIONAL
WAYS OF PRODUCING LITHIUM SO
ON. MY WAY OF CONTEXT OF COURSE
CALIFORNIA'S A NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL LEADER IN OUR
RENEWABLE ENERGY CLIMATE AND
CLIMATE GOALS THAT MAKES US A
LEADER AND WE VERY MUCH ARE A
LEADER IN DEPLOYING LITHIUM
BASED TECHNOLOGIES SUCH AS-
ELECTRIC VEHICLES THAT USE
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES AS WELL
AS- LITHIUM BASED BATTERIES
THAT HELP SUPPORT OUR ELECTRIC
GRID DURING CRITICAL THAT PEAK
HOURS- WERE ALSO AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION WE HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF HELPING SUPPORT-
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION A
LITHIUM EXTRACTION IN
CALIFORNIA AND- THAT'S BEEN. A
GREAT EFFORT TO- ASSESS
OPPORTUNITIES AND REALLY
EVALUATE OPPORTUNITIES- FOR
WITH THE INTRODUCTION OF THE
SALT SEA REGION AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING COMMUNITY DIALOGUE
AND ENGAGEMENT- GLOBAL TRENDS
ARE VERY MUCH IN THE DIRECTION
OF RAPID DEPLOYMENT OF CLEAN
ENERGY TECHNOLOGIES THAT
REQUIRE LITHIUM BUT REALLY
MASSIVE SCALES AND THIS.
POSITIONS CALIFORNIA AND- SOME
SEE READ. TO BE LEADER IN A
CALL SUPPLY CHAIN- THAT CAN. I
AM VERY INCLUDED FIRST
COMPONENT OF HOW. LITHIUM AND
ALSO RELATED INDUSTRIES THAT
TAKE ADVANTAGE URBAN USE THAT
UTILIZE THE LITHIUM AND THE
CLEAN ENERGY THAT WE HAVE IN
ABUNDANCE IN THE STATE. SO- THE
DEAL THERMAL BRIAN'S ON THAT
ARE ABOUT A HALF MILE BENEATH
THE SALTON SEA HAVE PROBABLY
WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT CERTAINLY
CURRENTLY BELIEVED TO BE THE
HIGHEST CONCENTRATION OF
LITHIUM CONTAINEDIN GEOTHERMAL
BRINES ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
AND RECOVERING LITHIUM FROM
THOSE BRIAN'S IS FUNDAMENTALLY
A VERY COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
PROCESS DONE THE WAY LITHIUM IS
CURRENTLY- MIND SO WELL THE TWO
WAYS A LITHIUM IS CURRENTLY
EXTRACTED RIGHT NOW. INCLUDE
HARD ROCK MINING AND THAT
FOLLOWS THE TRADITIONAL MINING
PROCESS WHERE HEAVY EQUIPMENT
IS USED TO REMOVE SOIL FIND
LIST AND FIND WITHIN RICH
DEPOSITS WITHIN HARD ROCK-
THOSE DEPOSITS ARE EXTRACTED
AND THEN THERE'S A CHEMICAL.
PROCESSING THAT'S DONE TO GET
THE LITHIUM OUT OF THOSE HARD
ROCK DEPOSITS ON THE MINING IS
ENVIRONMENTALLY- IMPACTFUL
OBVIOUSLY IN THAT IT CAN SCAR A
LANDSCAPES AND ADVERSELY AFFECT
ECOSYSTEMS AND HABITAT. IT'S
ALSO WATER AND ENERGY
INTENSIVE. IN CONTRAST TO THE
PROCESS AND THE OPPORTUNITY AT
THE SALTON SEA WHERE LITHIUM
RECOVERY CAN LITERALLY BE ANY
COPRODUCT OF CLEAN ENERGY
PRODUCTION- THE HARD ROCK ALL
RIGHT SO THE OTHER MAJOR OUR
METHOD FOR PRODUCING LITHIUM
TODAY. IS THE OF THE OPERATIVE
BRIAN PROCESSES USED X.
EXTENSIVELY IN PARTS OF SOUTH
AMERICA AND THIS PROCESS
INVOLVES PUMPING HIM BRIAN.
UNDERGROUND SURFACE POOLS
MIXING INTERLOCAL THAT HELP
SEPARATE OUT THE NON LITHIUM
CONSTITUENTS LETTING THEM STAY
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME THAT CAN
EXTEND FROM MONTHS TO YEARS. TO
EVAPORATE AND- TAKING EXPOSED
WITH. THE M. FOR FURTHER
PROCESSING SO. THIS PROCESS IS
IN- IT'S YOU KNOW VERY OFTEN
WATER INTENSIVE IN A DESERT
REGIONS SO IT IT'S GOT
SIGNIFICANT ECOLOGICAL AND
HUMAN IMPACTS IN MANY PLACES
WHERE- WHERE THIS TECHNOLOGY IS
WIDESPREAD. AND IT CAN REQUIRE-
THOUSANDS OF SQUARE MILES OF
LAND. SO IN CONTRAST TO THESE
TWO TECHNOLOGIES DIRECTOR
LITHIUM RECOVERY ALLOWS FOR A
VERY VERY SUSTAINABLE LITHIUM
SUPPLY. IT'S THE PROCESS OF
REMOVING LITHIUM FROM
GEOTHERMAL BRINE. ARE TYPICALLY
USING AN ENGINEERED MATERIAL
SURFACES THAT THE LITHIUM ION
IN THE BRINE IS ATTRACTED TO
AND STICKS TO SO BASICALLY THE
GEOTHERMAL BRINE IS BROADER FOR
WELLS IT'S USED TO GENERATE
ELECTRICITY THE VERY HOT BRINE
IS USED TO GENERATE ELECTRICITY
GEOTHERMAL PLANTS. AND THEN IT
WOULD BE FURTHER PROCESS TO-
GET THE LITHIUM OUT OF THE
BRIAN THERE ARE ACTUALLY A
COUPLE DIFFERENT WAYS THAT CAN
BE DONE ON IT AND THAT FELT
BETTER BEING DEMONSTRATED IN
THE SALT SEA AREA. AFTER THE
LITHIUM IS RECOVERED THE SPENT
BRIAN IS SENT BACK TO THE
GEOTHERMAL FACILITIES INJECTION
WELL AND IS RE INJECTED INTO
THE RESERVOIR AGAIN THE HALF
MILE OR SO DEEP. IN THE SALTON
SEA AREA DIRECT WITH HIM
RECOVERY IS USUALLY PERFORMED
ON SITE OR VERY NEAR THE
GEOTHERMAL FACILITY. IT IT CAN
BE AN OUT ON PROCESS TO
EXISTING GEOTHERMAL PLANTS SO
THE GEOTHERMAL PLANTS THAT ARE
THERE TODAY CAN BE MODIFIED. TO
ADD THIS PROCESS. AND ON A CAN
ALSO. BE ARE A PROCESS THAT'S
INTEGRATED INTO ANY NEW
GEOTHERMAL PLANTS BUILT IN THE
FUTURE. OF COURSE ARE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD TO MEET OUR
CLIMATE GOALS IN CALIFORNIA AND
MAINTAIN A RELIABLE ENERGY
SYSTEM WE'RE REALLY SEEING THE
VALUE OF THE CLEAN FOR POWER
THAT GEOTHERMAL PROVIDES AND IN
A RECENT- PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION DECISION THEY CALL
FOR- A THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF
CLEAN FIRM POWER WHICH I DO
THERMAL POWER IS ON THE SB ONE
HUNDRED WORK DONE BY THE JOINT
AGENCIES ALSO DEMONSTRATES OUR
SIGNALS. THERE IS A LONG TERM
VALUE TO THIS CLAIM FROM POWER
SO- YOU KNOW THE ENERGY
COMMISSION HAS PROVIDED
SUBSTANTIAL FUNDING SUPPORT
OVER SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
IN GRANTS- TO ADVANCE-
DEMONSTRATIONS AND RESEARCH IN
THE AREA OF LITHIUM RECOVERY-
PARTICULARLY CONSULTANC
BRIAN'S AND- WE'RE ALSO HELPING
SUPPORT. S. INNOVATIONS LITHIUM
COMPILED MANY. REDUCE AND
RECYCLING- I THINK THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT TOPIC AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY AND
TO THIS OFTEN AND APART ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
COMMISSIONER- I'M GOING TO ASK
THAT WE HOLD OFF ON QUESTIONS
STILL LOOM- THE END OF THE-
PRESENTERS OR PRESENTATIONS- WE
WANT TO- GO INTO THE NEXT PANEL
BUT WE DEFINITELY WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. D. WORDS THAT YOU
MENTION AS IT RELATES TO OTHER
READ HIM OPPORTUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE DAY. WITH
ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES HERE IS
CERTAINLY AN AREA THAT WE WANT
TO ALSO DIVE INTO AND TAKE A
LOOK AT- THE APPROACH THAT'S
BEING TAKEN THERE- THAT IS
CLEANER GREENER. AND PRESENTED
UNIQUE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY-
FOR THE STATE SO- WILL HOLD OFF
ON SOME QUESTIONS WILL GO INTO
OUR NEXT PRESENTER AND I HOPE
THAT YOU CAN- STAY WITH US SO
THAT- WE CAN ENGAGE YOU AS WE
GET READY TO ASK QUESTIONS. OUR
NEXT PRESENTER WE HAVE UP TO
FOLKS WHO WILL BE FOCUSED ON
FINANCING- LANDSCAPE OF- THIS
DISCUSSION DR RAMISH RAMA
MOORTHY CHAIR PROFESSOR IN
MATERIALS SCIENCE AND
ENGINEERING. AT UC BERKELEY AND
IS AN APPOINTEE- TO THE BYRON
HARRIS TRANSITION AGENCY. TO
REVIEW TEAM REVIEW TEAM I'M
SORRY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY- THEY'LL BE ON THE
SCREEN SHORTLY- AND THEN-
FOLLOWED BY- STEVEN BOYD
PROGRAM MANAGER- VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGIES OFFICE BATTERIES
ELECTRIFICATION FOR DEPARTMENT.
OF ENERGY AS WELL BOTH WILL BE
SPEAKING FOR ABOUT FIVE MINUTES
EACH SO- DEFIED DR IF YOU'RE
READY. U. S. SO YEAH THANK YOU-
GARCIA THANK YOU SOME MEMBERS
BUT TO SEE. WELL AS A QUICK
INTRODUCTION. I WAS A SOME SHOT
DIRECTLY WHICH WAS. PUT
TOGETHER TO LOOK AT THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES OF A LIFETIME. IN
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND
SOMETIMES TALK TO BE A VERY
SUCCESSFUL DEAL WE PROGRAM
BECAUSE WE HELPED. BRING THE
COST OF SOLAR ELECTRICITY DON
ACQUIT PARODY. I THOUGHT SAME
TIME THIS IS BACK IN
200-010-2000 TWELVE TIME FRAME.
AT THE SAME TIME I ALSO WAS THE
LEAD PI IN THE CRITICAL
MATERIALS HUB WHICH I'M GOING
TO GET TO IN A SECOND- DOC WAS
THE CRADLE TO GRAVE PROGRAMS ON
ASKING. THE QUESTION HOW DOES
ONE. WHAT TO OPTIMIZE BE. AND
LOOKING INTO IS ONE OF THE ONE
I'M GONNA ABOUT TODAY BUT OTHER
MINERALS WELL LIKE ROADS BOARD
TO TALK ALL OF THE- THERE WAS
INCREASE CONCERN ABOUT BEING
HELD HOSTAGE BY. NAY LAST TO
THIS YEAR I SORT OF THE-
PROPELLING BECAUSE BIDEN-
TRANSITION TEAM WHETHER. OF AND-
I HAD TWO OR THREE OLD SON ONE
OF THE AB SPECIFIC. TO DO WITH-
WHAT WE CALLED XBOX THE CHARGE
MORE THAN VERSIONS OF THE SO
CHART THE YOU POST FOR THE SUN
WAS TO TAKE THE POWER OF THE
NEW. THE FEDERAL DOES STATE GOT
THE PRIVATE SECTOR UNIVERSITIES
NATIONAL LABS BRING THEM
TOGETHER TO SOLVE THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS SUPPORT LIFETIME. AND
WE DON'T FIVE TORN PAPERS FLOW
CHARTS FOR THE BLIND AND
HARRISON. CROSSCUT FOR ALL OF
THEM WAS KNOWS OF CRITICAL.
COULD MEN. IN THEIR- ALL OF
THESE ARE TRUCKS CLEARLY THE
FIRST ONE OF THEM IS ENERGIES.
STEVEN WILL TALK THAT A SMALL-
THAT'S ALREADY OUT ON THE
OPENED UP IN THE OPEN.
DEPARTMENT OF G. NOW ALL OF
LOOKING FOR IDEAS ON ON HOW. TO
PROGRESS THAT. NOW BACK IN TWO.
AND SOME SHORT WAS STILL IN THE
EARLY STAGES- IT WAS VERY CLEAR
THAT THIS IS GOING TO WORK- I
WAS PUSHING STEVEN CHOI DID WE
SHOULD BECOME MORE AGGRESSIVE
IN TERMS OF THE METRICS THAT WE
WERE USING. IT WAS ALSO A- THE
ONE THING THAT COULD LOOK AT
SOLAR OR WIND FOR THAT MATTER.
IS THE FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
LOW COST- RIDGE IN THOSE DAYS
BATTERIES WERE ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A KILOWATT
HOUR. AN HOUR CALCULATIONS WERE
TELLING US THAT WE NEEDED TO
GET TO ABOUT THIRTY DOLLARS A
CAN OF. COURSE NOW WITH TESLA'S
BOB THE PRODUCT WE NOW HAVE THE
POSSIBILITY OF GETTING TO ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY DOLLARS A
KILOWATT HOUR BUT WE NEEDED TO
GET THE THIRTY DOLLARS HELLO.
SO IT WAS VERY CLEAR THE
REVENUE. ARE TO BE STRONG GET.
BY THE AVAILABILITY OF LOOK.
STORAGE MAYBE A WAYS OF STORING
BUT CLEARLY AT MINE BATTERY
WERE. THE MOST ATTRACT SO YOU
FOR THIS. NOT COMING TO LOOK AT
MY BATTERIES I SHOULD SAY THAT
AT MY BROTHERS WERE INVENTED
CAL. ACTUALLY L. B. BACK IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES PROFESSOR
COMBINED WAS OF THE EARLY PIE.
IN THIS FIELD SO IN CALIFORNIA
WE DO HAVE THE UNIVERSITIES ALL
THE UC IS WE DO WILL- THE
NATIONAL LABS. LAWRENCE
BERKELEY LAB WHICH ALL AGREE
DEEPLY ENGAGED IN I SHOULD SAY
THAT THEY'LL B. L. WHICH IS
WHERE I'M ALSO. EMPLOYED THE
BILL HAS A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM ON THE P. MIND
BATTERIES AND STEVEN WERE TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT IF YOU
ALL NEED TO SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND CAN COME IN AND
GIVE YOU A- BIGGER REFUND. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WAS VERY
GOOD I REMEMBER DOING THAT
PLEASE THREE BRIEFS SELECTED TO
GO ON A- ALL ON THE NEEDS
CRITICAL TOWARDS AN HOUR FOR
WAS TO. ON LOOKING BECAUSE
MONEY THAT THE- ELECTRIC OF. IS
GOING TO BE DEPENDENT ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF LITHIUM AND IF
YOU LOOK AT ALL THE NUMBERS TO-
DARK THAT DOES GOING TO BE A
HUGE GOOD OLD THE BABY FROM
ABOUT FORTY BILLION. DOLLAR
MARKET. IN TWENTY TEN. TO ABOUT
HOW FIFTY DOLLAR MARKET AND
27120% AND GROWTH APPROX. ONE
OF THE OTHER THING THAT WE-
REALLY- PUSHING VERY HARD
WITHIN OUR TRANSITION TEAM WHY
STILL AT PUBLIC PRIVATE. UNTIL
WE GET SOME. ABOVE FORTY BAHT
ENTITY AGENCY. ALSO MAYBE
TWENTY BILLION GOES INTO OUR
AND B. AND- THAT'S WHAT WE WERE
FOR A- WITH THE STATE. AND HE
TOLD US HAVE THEIR OWN RE. TO
HAVE NATURAL RESOURCES FISCAL
RESOURCES PEOPLE RESOURCES SO
ON AND SO FORTH AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR COMES IN AS THE OTHER.
PART OF THE PUZZLE SO WHAT WE
WERE PUSHING FOR. INTENSELY IN
OUR TRANSITION TEAM WANTS TO
HAVE A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP WHERE WE CAN COME
TOGETHER BRING THE NATION
TOGETHER TO SOLVE THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM SUPPORT LIFETIME. AND
WALKED WHAT A BIGGER PROBLEM
THAN ENERGY OR CLIMATE CHANGE-
THE REAL ENERGY STORAGE IS
PERHAPS THE FINAL FRONTIER. I'M
SORT OF SAYING THAT WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS BY WHICH YOU
KNOW THE STATE GOVERNMENTS OF
THE STATE OF. THE CORPORATE OF
ENERGY. I WILL LEAVE YOU WITH
JUST ONE PART AND I'M VERY
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AND
STEVEN WILL ELABORATE MORE FROM
THE- SITE. WHAT WE NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT IS INVENTED IN
CALIFORNIA OR THE UNITED STATES
FOR THAT MATTER. MADE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE MADE IN THE US
AND THEN SOARED WORD WHITE BOX
WHAT WE SHOULD BE A SPOTTING.
ON THE SIZE OF THESE MARKETS IS
NO MORE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IT'S TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS UNTIL
WE HAVE A FANTASTIC OPPORTUNITY
TO CAPTURE THIS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- GERMAN GARCIA HAVE
DECREASED SINCE THANK YOU DR-
WILL LOOK GET RIGHT INTO THE
NEXT PRESENTER AND WE'LL-
RESERVE. SOME TIME FOR SOME
QUESTIONS FOR YOURSELF AND THE
OTHER PRESENTERS ONCE WE
COMPLETE THE AT THE PANEL.
PRESENTATIONS THANK YOU STEVEN
BOYD PROGRAM MANAGER. VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGIES OFFICE- BATTERIES
ELECTRIFICATION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY IF YOU'RE
READY TO GO YOU'VE. GOT- FIVE
MINUTES THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
AND THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR THE
INTERACTION AS WELL- IT'S GOOD
TO TALK TO YOU ALL TO. I'LL TRY
TO MAKE IT- BUCKS OF THE AT
BUTTON. POINTS HERE. THE OTHER
OF WHICH IS TO- I WORK IN THE
TECH. OFFICE THE OF ENERGY.
WHERE PRIMARILY A ARE AND D.
ORGANISE. WE'VE BEEN MORE OUT
FOR A LONG TIME- IN. AND A
STORAGE FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
AND WE'RE REALLY SEEING THE-
ENJOYING THE SUCCESS- THAT ARE
INDIA'S HAD OVER THE YEARS AND-
CURRENTLY VERY EXCITEDABOUT
THE DIRECTION THAT ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. AND BATTERIES AND
ENERGY STORAGE YOU'RE TAKING.
I'M REALLY THAT IS OUR FOCUS
IS. IS BEGINNING TO LOWER COST
BATTERIES TO ENABLE- GREATER
GREATER SHARE OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES- BUT IN ADDITION TO
THAT WE HAVE- SOME SIGNIFICANT
PARTICIPATION- NOW IN SOME OF
THE SUPPLY CHAIN EFFORTS THAT
COULD SUPPORT- ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AT THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE SORT OF AT SCALE. IN
THE MARKETS THIS IS NOT THE
HUNDREDS OF. THOUSANDS OF
VEHICLES WE SEE TODAY. IT'S A
VEHICLES K. TO HAVE SOMEBODY
MISSED GO- AND ADDING
CALIFORNIA'S WELL TO SEE.
PORTION OF THE MARKET. AND SO
ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT- THAT
SUPPORTING THAT I THINK IT'S
BEEN MENTIONED IS THE
PRESIDENT'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
FOURTEEN OF SEVEN ON AMERICA
SUPPLY CHAINS. I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT OF THE FOUR
AREAS THAT ARE MENTIONED THERE
HIGH CAPACITY BATTERIES ARE ONE
OF THOSE WHICH VERY MUCH FALLS
WITHIN THE REALM OF- OF
LITHIUM. LITHIUM BASED
BATTERIES. THIS IS LOOK ACROSS
THE SUPPLY CHAIN UPSTREAM- IN
TERMS OF RAW MATERIALS
MIDSTREAM PROCESSING CELL
MANUFACTURING AND DOWNSTREAM-
FOR PACK MANUFACTURING TO-
APPLICATIONS INCLUDING ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. ALSO IT'S- THERE A
REPORT THAT- ARE OFF-
CONTRIBUTE TO THEM VERY
SIGNIFICANT WAY AND OTHERS I
THINK SOME IMPORTANT CONTENT
THAT'S WORTHWHILE MENTIONING IN
THAT SECTION. THIS REPORT DOES
HIGHLIGHT A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT- IMPORTANT AREAS AND
THOSE INCLUDE VULNERABILITY
ACROSS THE SORT OF UP IN MID
STREAM AND DOWNSTREAM- PARTS OF
THE BATTERY SUPPLY CHAIN- THIS
INCLUDES A LITHIUM. AS A AS A
PRIMARY SUPPLY CHAIN
PORTABILITY AND THAT THE US HAS
A SIGNIFICANT DEFICIT IN
MINERAL- REFINING AND
PROCESSING OF LITHIUM AS WELL
AS IN THE MID STREAM THAT WE
HAVE THE US HAS LESS THAN 2% OF
GLOBAL MARKET SHARE FOR
CAPACITY ACROSS ALL MAJOR
BATTERY COMPONENTS INCLUDING
SELF DEPRECATION. MOST OF THESE
ARE ALL CRITICAL AREAS IN
WHICH- WE ARE FOCUSING AS WELL
AS DOWNSTREAM FOR BATTERIES
WHERE THE US CURRENTLY LAGS
OTHER MARKETS IN TERMS OF
LITHIUM BATTERY RECYCLING WITH
LESS THAN 5% OF LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES RECYCLED EACH YEAR. I
ALSO. WANNA HIGHLIGHT THAT- IN
THIS REPORT- THERE'S A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT GOALS ARE PROBABLY
HIGHLIGHTED INCLUDING
STIMULATING DEMAND FOR
BATTERIES SO CREATING DEMAND BY
ELECTRIFYING FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL PURCHASES OF VEHICLES AND
BUSES. AS WELL AS POINT OF SALE
REBATES STRENGTHENING KEY
BATTERY MATERIALS SUPPLIES SUCH
AS- MEALS ACIDIC STRATEGIES
WITH IMPROVED ENVIRONMENTAL
LABOR STANDARDS AS WELL AS
ESTBLISHING COMPREHENSIVE
RECYCLING POP POLICY TO
DRASTICALLY INCREASE BATTERY
CAPTURE MATERIALS RECOVERY.
PROMOTING DOMESTIC BATTERY
MATERIALS CELL AND PACK
PRODUCTION. SO DOES
INCENTIVIZING PRIVATE
INVESTMENT THROUGH FEDERAL
GRANTS TAX CREDITS FEDERAL
LOANS AND LEVERAGING EXISTING
PROGRAMS SUCH AS OURS. AND AS
WELL AS INVESTING IN THE PEOPLE
AND INNOVATIONS THAT ARE GOING
TO SUPPORT THIS MARKET SERVICES
ADDITIONAL ARE INDEED TO MEET
UP FOREMAN'S AND COST TARGETS
SUCH AS- THAT WORK OUR
OFFICERS. AS. WELL AS-
DEVELOPING THE WORK FORCE- I
ALSO HIGHLY AS AN AS A PART OF
MY REMARKS TODAY. THAT WE-
KEENLY FOLLOWING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT AND
JOBS ACT. WHICH IS AGAIN
CONTINUING TO DEVELOP- ON BOTH
A CURRENT LEAD WHERE- FOCUSED
ON A FEW DIFFERENT SECTIONS OF
THAT BILL INCLUDING THAT
BATTERY MATERIAL PROCESSING
GRANTS- THIS IS FOR- UPSTREAM
AND MIDSTREAM LITHIUM BASED
BATTERY SUPPLY CHAIN WORK. THAT
CURRENTLY- CALLS FOR THREE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS
INVESTMENT FOR THAT AREA. AS
WELL AS MIDSTREAM AND
DOWNSTREAM BATTERY
MANUFACTURING AND RECYCLING
WORTH WORK ANOTHER THREE
BILLION THERE. AS WELL AS
DOWNSTREAM- THAT FOR LITHIUM
BATTERY RECYCLING THERE ARE A
FEW DIFFERENT AREAS INCLUDING-
CONTINUING ON OUR LITHIUM
BATTERY RECYCLING PRIZE THAT
DEALS WITH THE- THE SORTING.
STORAGE AND PROCESSING FOR
CURRENT LITHIUM ION BATTERIES
IN THE MARKET AS WELL AS
BATTERING CRITICAL MINERAL
RECYCLING AND BATTERY RECYCLING
RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT FOR
RESEARCH AND DEMONSTRATION
GRANTS THAT'S A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION. AND FINALLY TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FOR ELECTRIC
DRIVE VEHICLE BATTERY RECYCLING
AND SECOND LIFE APPLICATIONS
THAT'S USING THE BATTERIES A
DIFFERENT APPLICATION OTHER
THAN THE ORIGINAL VEHICLE. AT
THEIR END OF LIFE. FINALLY OUR
TO MENTION THAT YOU ALSO- PART
OF OUR OFFICE- YOU USE A WHOLE
IT DOES ON ON PRO OFTEN- THAT
LOW PROGRAMS OFFICE HAS- THIS.
REACHED OUT- TO- CRITICAL
MATERIALS- COMMUNITY AND- IN
AREAS SUCH AS LITHIUM
SPECIFICALLY FOR BATTERIES SO
THERE'S A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
MATERIALS THAT THEY FOCUSED ON
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AS PART OF THAT LOAN
PROGRAM- FOR THIS SORT OF A
CAPITAL EXPENSE. OKAY I'LL I'LL
IN THERE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU STEVE BOYD WE'RE
GOING TO GET A PERSPECTIVE
FROM. LOCAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT- FOLKS- THE NEXT
SPEAKER PANEL THREE WILL BE A
TIM KELLY PRESIDENCY OVER
PROBABLY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION. HE'LL BE TALKING A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE LOCAL AND
STATE- LANDSCAPE ON FINANCING-
MISS KELLY. GET THE BOUT FIVE
MINUTES PLEASE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SOME MEMBER GARCIA. A GOOD
MORNING. CALLING IN FROM- NASH
WHERE I JUST A- INCLUDED IN A-
YOU CAN DEVELOPMENT COUNCIL
ANNUAL CONFERENCE. IN WHICH I
THERE'S A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ELECTRONIC VEHICLES ENERGY
WORKFORCE AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THESE ARE ALL MAJOR TOPICS
THAT ARE GOING TO DISCUSS TODAY
AND THINGS ARE GOING AFFECT
THIS OF THIS INDUSTRY. I WANT
TO MAKE PHRASES YOU'RE GOING
HERE TODAY IS CLEAN LETS HIM.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
THAT. BECAUSE 75% OF OUR
BATTERIES IN THE WORLD ARE
PRODUCED IN CHINA AND POWERED
BY COAL POWER PLANTS. AND USE
LITHIUM. AND OTHER MINERALS
PRODUCED IN COUNTRIES WITH
DEVASTATING ENVIRONMENTAL
EFFECTS. CALIFORNIA'S LEADER IN
OUR INDIAN CONSUMPTION OF
BATTERY OPERATED VEHICLES AND
EQUIPMENT. WE CANNOT MAKE THE
MISTAKE AGAIN OF REGULATED
BUSINESSES AND PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THE BENEFITS OTHER
STATES AND COUNTRIES. WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF AN ENTIRE SUPPLY
CHAIN FROM THE LIQUID MINING TO
THE LITHIUM PURIFICATION
PROCESSING DISTRIBUTION. AND
LIFECYCLE RECYCLING. THE GIRL
COUNTY IS TAKING MANY STEPS. TO
POSITION OURSELVES FOR SUCH AN
OPPORTUNITY. WE ARE THE LEADERS
OF PRODUCTION OF GEOTHERMAL AND
SOLAR ENERGY AS WELL AS WIND
AND TRANSPORTATION FUELS.
LITHIUM EXTRACTION PURIFICATION
AND PROCESSES REQUIRES A LOT OF
ENERGY WATER AND LAND AND
WORKFORCE AND OF COURSE THE
MINERAL. ALL THESE ARE
AVAILABLE IN THE IMPERIAL
COUNTY. STEPS THAT WE'VE TAKEN
OVER THE DECADES PARTISAN
POSITION TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS INDUSTRY CLUSTER ARE AS
FOLLOWS. IN WILL COUNTY WAS
GIVEN PERMISSION TO PERMIT
POWER PLANTS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
YOU LOOK BELOW FIFTY MEGAWATTS
SINCE THEN WE HAVE. BUILT ABOUT
FIFTEEN YOUR THERMAL PLANTS ALL
OF THEM FORTY NINE POINT NINE
MEGAWATTS. WE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE THAT INCREASED TWO HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS TODAY TURBANS COULD
BE. A BUILT THE CONVERGENCE
NINETY FIVE MEGAWATTS WITHTHE
ECONOMIST GAIL IN THE ENERGY
THAT'S NEEDED FOR THIS INDUSTRY
THAT'S THE DIRECTION THAT WE
NEED TO GO. INTEL COUNTING
DEVELOP TO GEOTHERMAL OVER LATE
WHICH EXPEDITES THE PERMITTING
FOR GEOTHERMAL PLANTS. WE CAN
PERMITTED YOUR THERMAL PLANT IN
ABOUT EIGHTEEN MONTHS IN THE
CALL COUNTY THAT'S ABOUT THE
BARE MINIMUM. WE GOT A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE DOING THAT AND WE
THINK THAT- WITHOUT OVERLAYING
AND WITH THE INCREASE. OF AND
THE MEGAWATTS THAT WE CAN
PERMIT LOCALLY WOULD CREATE A
BONE TO THIS INDUSTRY. WE ALSO
DEVELOPED A RENEWABLE ENERGY
OVERLAY WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF
THE- PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION WHICH IDENTIFIES
IDEAL LOCATIONS FOR RENEWABLE
ENERGY. WITH THE LEAST
INTERRUPTION TO THE VALUABLE
AGRICULTURAL LAND AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. THAT IS CORRECT
THE PLACE. WE'VE DEVELOPED
LARGE SPECIFIC PLANNED AREAS
CONTINUE FACTORING THE GATEWAY
TO THE AMERICAS HIS THREE
THOUSAND ACRES LOCATED ON THE
MEXICAN BORDER THAT THE SPORT
OF ENTRY DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY
FOR INTERNATIONAL TRADE AND
ASSEMBLY. KEYSTONE PLANNING
AREA IS FIVE THOUSAND ACRES. NO
SPECIFIC PLAN AREA AND THREE
THOUSAND ACRES THE GENERAL
PLANNED AREA ONCE AGAIN IN A
LOCATION THAT'S GOING HAVE
LEAST INTERRUPTION TO
AGRICULTURE AND DESIGNED FOR
MEDIUM AND HEAVY MANUFACTURING.
VERY INTERESTING IN THE
DEVELOPING A THIRD SPECIFIC
PLAN AREA NEAR THE SALTON SEA
LAUNCH IT FROM A RESOURCE AREA.
THIS IS WHERE THE BRIDE WILL BE
PRODUCED. WE'LL BE PRODUCING
THE ENERGY AND WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXTRACT AND
PURIFY IN ONE LOCATION NOT TO
MENTION THE ULTRA TRACKED THE
MANUFACTURING. SO WHAT IS
HOLDING US BACK. YOUR PROVIDER
KELLY. HOWEVER THE DISTRICT IN
THE SOLVENCY BUDGETS ARE MORE
RESOURCE AREA AS IS THE CURRENT
SHARE OF THE LOOKING VALLEY
COMMISSION AND HAS BEEN HOLDING
MANY FORCING FOCUS GROUPS ON
THE FOLLOWING TOP BOX FIRST OF
ALL INFRASTRUCTURE CONSULTANCY
BECAUSE YOU'RE A LACKS MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE'VE
IDENTIFIED THE ROADS. THE
BRIDGES. BROADBAND RAIL WALL.
ALL THE ROADS LEADING TO THAT
AREA ARE MAINLY DIRT ROADS AND
THE BRIDGES ALL NEED TO BE
REPLACED OR REPAIRED. IN AN
AREA THAT HAS BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS INVESTING IN GEOTHERMAL
THERE IS NO BROADBAND AND SO
THAT'S A MAJOR NEED FOR US TO
BRING BROADBAND INTO THAT AREA
AND WE'RE WORKING ON THAT.
PERMITTING AS I MENTIONED WE
NEED TO INCREASE OUR
CAPABILITIES OF LOCAL
PERMITTING. AND REQUESTING
FUNDING FOR COUNTY TO BE ABLE
TO DO ADDITIONAL STUDIES. TO
SPEED UP THE PROCESS OF OUR
MEETING IN OUR COUNTY. PACIFIC
LIFE FOR THE PURIFICATION
MANUFACTURING WE'VE ALREADY
DONE A GREAT JOB WITH THE GYM
THERMAL. AND RENEWABLE ENERGY
OVERNIGHT. OUR WORK FORCE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY PUBLIC COLLEGE. AND
EVEN STUDIES UNIVERSITY IN
INDUSTRY AND LOOKING AT HOW
THEY COULD PROVIDE THE
WORKFORCE FOR THE FUTURE NEEDS.
I AM PROUD COUNTY WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD IS WORKING ON
WAYS TO FINANCE AND TRAIN
EMPLOYEES FROM THE YOUTH TO
POSTGRADUATE. IMPERIAL COUNTY
ENTIRE COUNTY IS A FOREIGN
TRADE ZONE. WHICH MEANS THAT WE
CAN NOT ONLY IMPORT BUT WE CAN
ALSO EXPORT GOODS INTO FOREIGN
TRADE ZONES AND OTHERS FOR VERY
LOW COST. ALSO TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF THE U. S. MCA IN DOING THAT.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO RECYCLING
OUR ENTIRE COUNTY IS ALSO A
RECYCLE MATERIAL DEVELOPMENTS
ON. A PROGRAM THAT HAS SOME
LIMITATIONS BUT I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THAT COULD BE
WORKED ON AS AN EXAMPLE THERE'S
A CAP ON FUNDING FOR TEN
MILLION DOLLARS. MOST THE
PROJECT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE ARE IN EXCESS OF ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AND IMPERIAL COUNTY IS
A LOT OF THE LOCATION WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT I WOULD WORK TO
RECYCLE THOSE MATERIALS AND
TURN THEM INTO OTHER OTHER
THINGS. ASSISTING OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES WORKING WITH THE
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER. AND THE C. M. D. C. TO
DEVELOP PROGRAMS AND HELP
EXISTING BUSINESSES AND NEW
BUSINESSES TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
COMING OUR WAY. IMPERIAL COUNTY
IS AN IDEAL PLACE TO CAPTURE
THE ENTIRE SITE SUPPLY CHAIN-
OF THIS INDUSTRY THAT IS BEFORE
US BUT WE REALLY NEED TO STAY
AHEAD OF THE CURVE. AND THE WAY
THAT WE NEED TO DO THAT IS WITH
SOME THINGS I JUST MENTIONED BE
PREPARED AND WORKING ON ALL
THESE THINGS AT THE SAME TIME
TODAY. THANKS OUR ENERGY. IS
GOING TO THEIR PERMITTING HAS
RECEIVED PERMITS THEY ARE
COMMITTED TO BUILDING A PILOT
PROJECT. IN A COMMERCIAL
PROJECT WILL BE SCALABLE FOR
THE FUTURE. ENERGY SOURCE JUST
RECEIVED THEIR PERMITS LAST
WEEK. I FOR THEIR LITHIUM
EXTRACTIONS WERE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT. CONTROLLED THERMAL
RESOURCES NEW COMPANY IS
LOOKING AT BUILDING. ITS FIRST
PHASE NINETY FIVE MEGAWATT
GEOTHERMAL PLANT WHICH WILL BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE INNER CITY
AND THE MINERALS THAT CAN BE
EXTRACTED FOR THIS INDUSTRY.
ALL THESE CUTS ALL THESE
BUSINESSES AND THE OTHERS THAT
WERE WORKING WITH. ARE VERY
CAREFUL NOT TO OVER PROMISE AND
UNDER DELIVER. A REALISTICALLY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IS HE
TARGET DATE THAT WE'RE LOOKING
LOOKING AT IT SEEMS LIKE A LONG
WAY OFF. BUT THAT'S WHAT IT'S
GOING TO TAKE IN ORDER TO
PERMIT. CONSTRUCT AND- FINANCE.
INDUSTRIES FINANCING IS THE KEY
HERE AND SO AS WE'VE BEEN
MOVING ALONG WITH THESE
COMPANIES FOR MANY YEARS IT'S
PROVING A DE RISKING THE
INDUSTRY SO THAT WE CAN ATTRACT
THE FINANCING. ADDUCTION TAX
CREDITS IS AN EXAMPLE OF A
FEDERAL PROGRAM WHICH WAS DOES
NOT BENEFIT GEOTHERMAL ENERGY.
TAKES EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO BUILD
A GEOTHERMAL PLANT PRODUCTION
TAX CREDITS THE DION AFFECT
TWELVE MONTHS AFTER YOU BREAK
GROUND. THAT'S ONE EXAMPLE OF
HOW A CERTAIN CERTAIN PROGRAMS
DO NOT BENEFIT THIS INDUSTRY
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE THE
CALIFORNIA WE COULD WORK ON
THAT TOGETHER. WE'VE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL BUT WITH THE DARK
CAL COMPETES PROGRAM FOR THESE
BUSINESSES AND IMPERIAL COUNTY-
CHALLENGES THERE IS THAT- YOU
HAVE TO HAVE EXTERNAL
COMPETITION FROM OTHER STATES
AN ORDINANCE THAT. AND SO
THERE'S A FOCUS ON THE LITHIUM
INDUSTRY THEN I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BENEFIT US
LOCALLY- THE REASON FOR THAT
IS. BECAUSE THIS GENTLEMAN
ANOMALY IS ONLY INDIAN GIRL
COUNTY. THERE'S NO PLACE IN IN
THE UNITED STATES THAT HAS THIS
RESOURCE AT THE VOLUME THAT WE
HAVE. IN ADDITION TO THAT IT
THIS INDUSTRY REQUIRES A LOT OF
WATER AND A LOT OF ENERGY. OUR
POTENTIAL FOR GEOTHERMAL ENERGY
IN THE GIRL COUNTY IS PROBABLY
ONLY ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT. AND
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY
TO EXPAND THAT AS WE EXPAND THE
JEWS THE GEOTHERMAL POWER
PLANTS WERE ALSO SPENT
EXPANDING. THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE EXTRACTION OF THE MIRROR OF
THE MINERALS SO THEREFORE WILL
BUILD PRODUCE THE POWER IN THE
MINERALS AT THE SAME TIME.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU LOOK AT. IF YOU THINK
ABOUT AND- IN THIS OF. ARE THEY
ARE CHALLENGE THEIR ON THE BACK
AND THEN AND NOT ON THE FRONT
END. AND MY OPINION IS THAT
INCENTIVES DON'T MAKE ABOUT POP
OBJECT GOOD TO MAKE A GOOD
PROJECT GREAT. AND THAT'S WHERE
WE NEED HELP WITH A COUPLE OF
THESE PROGRAMS. WHAT'S THE
NUMBER ONE CENTER WE CAN HAVE
WORKFORCE. RIGHT IS THERE A WAY
THAT WE CAN DEVELOP PROGRAMS
THAT ARE THESE INDUSTRIES HIRE
LOCAL PEOPLE AND TRAIN LOCAL
PEOPLE. THAT THEY WILL RECEIVE
THE FUNDING TO DO THAT THEN
THAT WOULD BE. HUGE WE'RE
LOOKING AT AN INDUSTRY THAT'S A
GAME CHANGER FOR COUNTY COUNTY
THAT HAS. A HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN THOUSAND PEOPLE. I WE
HAVE- THE HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT.
WE HAVE PEOPLE WORKING TOGETHER
TO TRY TO TRY TO IMPROVE THE
OPPORTUNITIES IN OUR COUNTY AND
RETAIN OUR WORK FORCE. AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE COULD DO
THAT. SO WITH BUT LOOKING AT
THAT WE CAN'T MAKE THE MISTAKE
THAT WE MADE WITH SOLAR. WHICH
IS REQUIRED THAT WE HAVE SOLAR
IN THE IN THE STATE OF.
CALIFORNIA AND THAT WE DON'T
CREATE THE OPPORTUNITIES
INCENTIVES. TO BE ABLE TO. A
PRODUCES ALL PLANTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THERE'S
THINGS THAT THE WORK TO BE DONE
TO MAKE US COMPETITIVE. AND TO
ATTRACT INDUSTRIES. ANOTHER
THING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE PUSHING PUSHING FOR.
IS TO CHANGE THE OPPORTUNITY
ZONES. I WHICH IS A MECHANISM.
THE OPPORTUNITY ZONES ARE NOT
AVAILABLE IN THIS AREA- OF THE-
SALTON SEA GEOTHERMAL RESOURCE
THERE- AN ERROR IN THE-
CONTRACT. OVER TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS INVESTMENT. AND SO AS I
MENTIONED A LOT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. YOU CAN
PLACE WORKFORCE TRAINING. OUR
TRAINING IT'S- JUST IN
BUSINESS- BUT WE HAVE THE
RESOURCE WE HAVE THE DESIRE WE
HAVE A COUNTY THAT SUPPORT THE
GROWTH. AND THE OPPORTUNITIES
WITH PUTTING A LOT OF THINGS
AND PLACES I MENTIONED. MEETING
ON A REGULAR BASIS. THAT WE ARE
PREPARED IN WILL BE PREPARED
FOR THE THINGS THAT WERE.
LOOKING AT TO IDENTIFY WITH THE
FUTURE NEEDS ARE. JOB HOPPING
SAID I. WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY BIGGER. I WANT
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT ON. A THE
DISCUSSIONS I'VE HAD WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF. ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AND THAT WERE
WORKING ON THIS TOGETHER. AND
THAT- AS- WE ARE TRYING TO COME
UP WITH THAT THE SOLUTIONS THAT
ARE GOING. NOT ONLY BENEFIT
THIS INDUSTRY BUT A TRACKED
OTHER MANUFACTURING. TO THE
GIRL COUNTY. AND WE DO NEED
HELP TO DO THAT- IT THAT'S WHY
WE'RE TALKING TODAY AND WERE
WILLING. TO LISTEN. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU PUBLIC
FOR QUITE. THANK YOU MISTER.
WE'RE GOING TO- HOLD OFF ON THE
QUESTION WE WILL GO INTO THE
NEXT- PRESENTING PANELIST
DANIEL FITZ GERALD. THE ACTING
REGIONAL FOR THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY SBDC NETWORK- FOLLOWED
BY TOM SOTO COMMISSIONER. ON
THE LYDIA VALLEY COMMISSION
FOUNDING MANAGING PARTNER OF
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES IMPACT
FUND. AND LATIMER PARTNERS LLC
HILLS ALSO HAVE FIVE TO EIGHT
MINUTES- TO PRESENT. THE FIRST
PERSON WILL BE A DAY OF HIS JOE
IF YOU'RE ON PLEASE- WELCOME.
INTO GOOD TO HAVE YOU THIS
MORNING HERE WITH US. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT'S GOOD TO BE
HERE AND BE ABLE TO TALK ON
THIS- AND I APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION AND THE INVOLVEMENT
THAT THE AT THE ASSEMBLY HASN'T
AND ASKING THE SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER. A PROGRAM
TO BE HERE. AS MR KELLY
MENTIONED WE'RE WE'RE A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS ASPECT SO I RECEIVED
ONE OF THE READ FIVE REGIONAL
ETWORKS YOU'RE IN CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER WHICH IS EIGHT FIVE
PROGRAM FUNDED BY THE US SMALL
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION. BUT
ALSO SIGNIFICANTLY SUPPORTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE AND TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. I THROUGH THAT IT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROGRAM IN THE CAPITAL INFUSION
PROGRAM. SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS WE HAVE A
MISSION TO HELP BUSINESSES FROM
IDEATION TO EXIT NOT THE WORST
HIGHER LIFE CYCLE ONE OF THE
MAIN COMPONENTS OF THAT IS TRUE
FINANCING. WE WORK ON WITH BOTH
GAS FINANCING AS WELL AS EQUITY
FINANCING AND SOMETHING TO TALK
A BIT ABOUT TODAY WHICH IS
SOMETIMES CALLED TECHNICALLY
NON DILUTIVE FINANCING WHICH IS
SIMPLY TERMS ARCHITECT RANTS.
BUDGET RESEARCH. GRANTS IN THE
STORE. AND SO WHAT OF THE I
WANTED. AS MR KELLY ABLE TO DO.
SOME OF THAT LARGER. AROUND
THERE'S- YOU KNOW BURKE HALF.
CERTAINLY IS NOT A SMALL
BUSINESS THERE'S A- OF. A
BUSINESS ATTENTION OR NEW CHECK.
THE AROUND WITH EXTRA. OR THE
DEVELOP OF DIFFERENT OF THE
YOUNG ALL THE WAY TO USED ABOUT
RESPECT. AND ANOTHER WITH A
WHOLE LOT. ENTREPRENEUR THAT IS
GOING INTO INNOVATOR BASED THIS
OR CHECK. BASED BUSINESS. YEAH.
ARCHDUKE'S DAMAGE BUSINESS
HOUSING DIFFERENT TACK NEEDS
AND SO THEY NOT GOING TO BE
NEEDING TO GET TYPE OF. TO AND
IS THERE MORE COMMENTS HI TAX
CREDIT WERE WERE THINGS LIKE
THAT RATHER WHAT NEED SIMPLE
TERMS CAPITAL AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE PREDOMINANTLY AFTER AND
THEN THE OTHER COMPLY WHICH IS
WHERE THE SMALL BUSINESS THE-
CENTER COMES. WHICH IS THE
TECHNICAL SYSTEM LET'S NAVIGATE
TO GET TYPES OF THAT ARE OUT
THERE IN WORKING WITH EITHER
YOU KNOW HOW NAVIGATE COUNTY.
RUN LIKE THIS AND TO BE ABLE TO
FIND A TAX EVERY. SO OF THE
MAIN ELEMENT FOR A- FOR. I
WANTED TO BRING UP THAT YES
NIECE WE DO OF FOR FIRST
BUSINESS INNOVATION RESEARCH
GRANTS ARE. COURT OUT THERE ARE
DESIGNS. FOR COME. I THESE ARE
OUR YOUR CALL. FOR DIFFERENT.
AID EVERYTHING FROM. OUR VERY
COMMON IN THIS DIEGO AREA FROM
THE NOW INSTITUTE OF HEALTH
NATIONAL. FOUNDATION AROUND
LIKE SCIENCE. ALSO WATER AROUND
THE PARKING OF DEFENSE MANY US
FROM WITH NOW ARE YOU. IN THE
GOT THAT'S A- OTHER PARTS OF
THIS. YOU IS CALM AND
PARTICULARLY IN THE CENTER
VALLEY. AND USGA. OR WOULD GO
SUPPORT USED. OR QUESTIONS AT.
YEAH THERE'S ALSO DEPARTMENT
ENERGY. THEY HAVE A VERY.
AMOUNT OF I GRANT AND THINGS
THAT. IS OF CALIFORNIA ALL. A
BALLOT IN THIS. THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA. COMMISSION AND I
KNOW THE I C. O. WITH TAX THE
ECHO AND ONE OF OUR PART. YEAR
IS PART OF S. B. C. NETWORK
THAT AN ACCURATE DIEGO. AS DONE
SOME OF WORK AROUND. DIFFERENT
TYPES OF CLEANING AND TECH.
YEAH WHEN I WAS OUT TO TALK
WHAT ARE SOME OF THOSE. EIGHTY
CALIBER COULD DO THIS TO EXPAND
INSISTED THOSE OF PROGRAMS.
THAT IS WHAT IS NOT. YOUR NEEDS
AS THEY DEVELOP THESE TAX.
ASTOR AT ME WAYS. BUT THE NEXT.
WHAT USE LITHIUM WORKING AT
DEMAND. TECHNIQUES ARE. BECAUSE
THESE ARE ON. TECHNOLOGY WHICH
MAY THERE IS AN PARTICULAR
MARKET. RATS OR SOMETHING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTED THEMSELVES. THAT
ALLOWS THESE TECHNOLOGIES TO BE
DEVELOPED IN THE FUNDO WHERE
THEY HAD THAT ENTREPRENEURS
ABLE TO FOCUS ON DEVELOPING THE
TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPING THE
MARKET PLACE FOR IMPROVING THAT
MARKET PLACE. BECAUSE WHAT WILL
HAPPEN IS AFTER THREE TO SAY
NINE YEARS OF DEVELOPING THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING TO SELL THAT. TO
COMPANIES LIKE BERKSHIRE
HATHAWAY. AND THAT'S REALLY THE
LIFE CYCLE OF THAT PARTICULAR
BUSINESS AND THAT'S WHERE
THEY'RE GONNA BE LOOKING OUT
HUESO WHAT'S THERE. SO HAVING
THAT TYPE BONTA WHO GRANT BASED
FINANCING I CAN'T WAIT SPECIFIC
RATHER APPLYING S. B. I. R. HAS
APPROVED ALL THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION IS DONE.
SAMPLES YES THOSE TYPES OF
CONTINUED FUNDING ARCO'S ARE
THINGS THAT YOU ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT AND VERY VERY SOLID
OPTIONS FOR FINANCING. THAT
ALLOWS THOSE COMPANIES TO. OF
COURSE YOU'RE ALSO WAS THE
EQUITY COME. IN OUR TALK TO
WHICH- ABOUT THAT ANOTHER.
THAT'S WHERE ALL. WE COME PLAY
AND- SPEAKING IN THE SUPPORT
FOR THAT. IT CAN CAN. TO
COMMENT AS WELL AS SUPPORT.
YEAH IDEAS HOW WE HELP FOLKS BE
ABLE TO SEEK OUT EACH OR
PASTORS BE ABLE TO DEVELOP WHAT
THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND
EVERYTHING THAT THE STRATEGIES
THEY NEED TO PUT TOGETHER. MORE
TO WORK WITH THE POTENTIAL
FINANCIAL FASTER TO WORK WITH
VENTURE FUNDS IN OTHER WORDS TO
REALLY BE ABLE TO BUILD UP THAT
FINANCING THEY NEED TO DEVELOP
THEIR TECHNOLOGIES DEVELOP
THEIR BUSINESS AND ALSO
DETERMINE WHAT THOSE PARTICULAR
MARKETS ARE. AND THOSE ARE
CRITICAL SUPPORTS. BESIDES THAT
THE STATE ALREADY HAS.
EXCELLENT FINANCING TO WE WHICH
I THINK THERE STUPID THINGS
THAT COULD BE LOOKED AT. IT
COULD POTENTIALLY FALL JUST. AS
THE AS THE TECHNOLOGIES
DEVELOPED. I I'VE BEEN ALREADY
DOESN'T. JOB AND DOING SOME
LOAN GUARANTEES THAT'S CLEARLY
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL MODEL FOR
THAT THAT'S TRUE TO FINANCIAL
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATIONS HERE
IN THE CDA. REGIONAL F. CAL
SOUTHERN THERE'S FIVE OTHER
FTC'S THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND
HE'S BASICALLY WORK JUST LIKE
HOW THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION. GUARANTEED BOX
OR MORAL AREAS HOW DO U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
GUARANTEES BOX. THANKS WHILE
THESE TYPES OF LOANS BECAUSE
THE STATE IS TAKING THE RISK
AWAY FROM THE PARTICULAR
LENDER. AND ALLOW THEM TO BE
ABLE TO CHECK THAT PARTICULAR.
ANSWER CONTINUING TO DEVELOP
THOSE TYPES OF OPTIONS AND
FINDING CREATIVE WAYS WHERE
THESE LAUNCH OF THESE TYPES OF
FINANCING CAN ALSO BE
DEVELOPED. IT'S COULD BE
CENTRAL TO THE FUTURE.
CHANGELLY THERE MAY BE OPTIONS
EVEN UNDER PROGRAM IS COMING
OUT FROM U. S. TREASURY CALLED
THE STATE SUPPLEMENTAL BUSINESS
CREDIT INITIALLY. S. S. B. C.
I. THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WOULD
HAVE TO OPTIONS AS WELL. OKAY I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
KIND OF TALK ABOUT THIS THIS IS
AN EXCITING DEVELOPMENT
TECHNOLOGY. YOU KNOW THERE'S
NEW THIS CAN BE A NEW POCKET
DEVELOPMENT DIFFERENT TYPES OF
TECHNOLOGIES NEW OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ENTREPRENEURSHIP. AND
CERTAINLY I THINK THERE THERE
ARE CERTAIN CREATIVE WAYS THE
PACKAGE SO I CAN APPRECIATE I.
YEAH YOU KNOW I CAN UNDERSTAND
QUESTIONS. HERE THANK YOU GET
NERVOUS BECAUSE JOE WILL UP. GO
INTO THE NEXT PRESENTER THAT'S
UP. TOWN SO- THE COMMISSIONER
ON THE. LET HIM VALLEY
COMMISSIONS SORT OF. GARCIA
MEMBERS OF THE CA THANK FOR.
INVITING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY I
THINK- THE INTENT OF MY-
STATEMENT REALLY IS GOING TO BE
FOCUSED AROUND. WHY SOMEONE
LIKE MYSELF WHO'S A LONG TIME
INVESTOR AND CLEAN TACK IT
CLEAN NERGY- SEES THIS AS AN
ATTACK ATTRACTIVE- SECTOR TO
DEVELOP LEADERSHIP AND GOOD
ECONOMICS- I DON'T THINK THAT
THERE IS ANYTHING MORE
FAVORABLE IN THE COUNTRY THEN
WORKING WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE HAVE. THE
DIFFERENCE HERE IS THAT WE HAVE
THE LEADERSHIP AND THE WILL TO
EXECUTE THE STRATEGY AND
COMBINE THAT WITH US BEING THE
CRADLE OF INNOVATION THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY ON PLANET EARTH
AND THE FACT THAT WE HAVE THE
TO THE GENETICS OF BEING ABLE
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE. IT'S ALL
THERE AND AS A REMEDIATION
DANIEL AND EVERYBODY ELSE
APPOINTED TO ALL OF THOSE
FACTORS HELP TO DE RISK THE
EQUITY THAT COME IN- THIS IS NO
ACCIDENT THAT WE HAVE THE
PROFOUND AMOUNT OF- EDUCATIONAL
CAPACITY WHAT ARE YOU SEE IN
CAL STATE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. THE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS AN
INCREDIBLE RESOURCE NOT JUST TO
US BUT WAS A BEACON FOR OTHER
PLACES THE PLANET TO FOLLOW OUR
HIGHWAY INFRASTRUCTURE- YOU
KNOW WE ARE OUR OUR CAPACITY TO
INNOVATE- COMES FOR MARK TIED
HERE GAINES. IT WENT TO THE
MANHATTAN PROJECT WHICH HELPED
TO ESTABLISH SILICON VALLEY
WHICH HELPED TO ESTABLISH THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
REVOLUTION WHICH HELPED TO
ESTABLISH. THE FOURTH
INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION. MY
PURCHASE A IN THIS MARKET HAS
MUCH MORE TO DO WITH LEADERSHIP
AND ECONOMICS BECAUSE THE
ECONOMICS FOLLOW. FROM THERE.
WE HAVE THE WELL WE HAVE THE
DESIRE AND WE HAVE THE MARKET.
SO MY POINT IN CONTRIBUTED TO
THIS DISCUSSION ES. WHAT IS IT
THAT WE NEED IN THE INVESTMENT
COMMUNITY IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS IS NOT A LOSS LEADER
THAT THE ECONOMICS HERE. ARE
NOT ONLY HAVE BEEN PROVED OUT
BUT THERE IS GOING TO BE NEW
TERRITORY. ALL OF THIS IS
HAPPENING IN THE MIDST OF HUGE
CRISIS THAT. PEOPLE CALL LIKE
SIX STANGEL I JUST CALL IT A
REAL CRISIS THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS THIS IS
JUST A MORAL- TRAGEDY THAT
WE'VE LET IT GET THIS FAR
WITHOUT RESPONDING. AND AS BILL
CLINTON USED TO SAY NEVER LET A
GOOD CRISIS GO TO WASTE SO HERE
WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF A HUGE
JOB TURN WHERE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS HUGE RESERVES-
THE ECONOMICS OF KOBE ED. ARE
QUICKLY GETTING BEHIND US WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT A LITTLE BIT OF
INFLATION BUT IS WHAT IS IT
THAT WE COULD DO TO INCENSED
FOLKS LIKE MYSELF TO COME INTO
THE VALLEY. AND BEGAN TO
CONVERT. IMPERIAL VALLEY INTO
WHERE IT SHOULD BE. WHERE WE
ALL INTENDED TO BE AND THAT IS
TO BE A BEACON. OF SOUND LONG
TERM ECONOMIC SECOND HELP TO
CONTRIBUTE TO IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THE PEOPLE
NOT JUST OF IMPERIAL VALLEY BUT
OF THE UNITED STATES IN
CALIFORNIA. IN PARTICULAR WE
HAVE TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF
RESOURCES HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVED OUT THERE WOULD BE NO
TESLA. WITHOUT A CARD. THERE
WOULD BE NO INTEREST IN THE
SECTOR WITHOUT EMISSION
CREDITS. THE BOOKENDS OF ALL OF
THESE. INNOVATIONS OCCUR NOT
BECAUSE YOU HAVE GREAT
ENTREPRENEURS BUT YOU HAVE A
GREAT ENTREPRENEURS WHO HAVE
CAPACITY TO GET THAT NON
DILUTIVE LIKE DANIEL WAS
TALKING ABOUT THAT GIVES ME
OUTSIZED RETURNS ON THE BACK
AND WHEN I GO TO THE
SHAREHOLDERS WHO WERE THE
SHAREHOLDERS WELL IT'S PROBABLY
GOING TO BE HUGE PUBLIC EQUITY.
HOLDERS WHITE CALPERS AND CAL
STIRS WHOM WE SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGING TO INVEST IN THIS
AREA BECAUSE THERE IS GOING TO
BE A HUGE MULTIPLE THERE AS
WELL FOR THE PENSIONERS YOU
KNOW BY THE WAY. 40% OF THOSE
PENSIONERS AND DEFINED
CONTRIBUTORS LOOK LIKE PEOPLE
ON THIS SOON CALL. THEIR LOW
INCOME THERE ARE HARD WORKING
LABOR. UNION ORGANIZED WORKERS
WHO ARE MOSTLY DIVERSE AND THEY
SHOULD SERVE AND GET THE
BENEFIT OF THE INVESTMENT IN
THIS AREA SPECIFICALLY WE HAVE.
THE CALIFORNIA POLLUTION
CONTROL FINANCE AUTHORITY IN
THE TREASURER'S OFFICE SECOND
HELP TO UNDERWRITE AND PROVIDE
NON DILUTIVE DEBT TO THESE
TYPES OF PROJECTS- WE HAVE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF CAPACITY
WITH. THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
COMMERCE THROUGH THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ADMINISTRATION
WHICH IS NOW UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP. OF OUT OF-
ALEXANDER CASIO RECENTLY
APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT BY- WE
HAVE A HUGE AMOUNT OF WIND IN
OUR SAILS BECAUSE THERE'S A
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA'S
APPOINTED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY. I JUROR SHOPPER
GENERATE CAPITALS NOW HEAD OF
THE DEAL WE LOAN PROGRAM THAT'S
FORTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
ITS OWN RIGHT KAREN SKELTON A
SENIOR ADVISER TO SECRETARY
GRANT. SECRETARY RANDOM
ALTHOUGH FORMER GOVERNOR OF
MICHIGAN I CONSIDER AN HONORARY
CALIFORNIA SO I THINK THAT WE
HAVE A HUGE AMOUNT OF CAPACITY
THAT. WE CAN GET BEHIND THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND NEWLY UP.
SOON TO BE REELECTED SENATOR
ALEX PADILLA TO HELP TO SUPPORT
THESE INITIATIVES AS WELL. THAT
IS THE TYPE OF DYNAMIC THAT
FOLKS LIKE I LOOK FOR IN ORDER
TO INVEST THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WILL BE NECESSARY
TO DEVELOP WHAT WE KNOW IS THE
FOURTH LARGEST RESERVE OF
LITHIUM ON PLANET EARTH. AND IS
CARRYING IT MENTIONED EARLIER
IT IS A MORE SUSTAINABLY
DEVELOP A BALL SOURCE OF
LITHIUM THAN ANY PLACE ON EARTH
AS WELL ALL AND BY THE WAY THE
BEST WAY TO ACCESS IT IS THE
INCREASED MORE RENEWABLE POWER.
BY CREATING MORE GEO THERMAL
ENERGY WHICH- BY THE WAY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA JUST PUT
OUT A DEMAND BY THE PC FOR
TWELVE THOUSAND MORE MEGAWATTS
OF NET DISPATCHABLE RENEWABLE
POWER. DISPATCHABLE IS SPINNING
RESERVE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
RENEWABLE POWER AND TO ME THAT
SAYS GEOTHERMAL BIOMASS AND
STORAGE SO THERE'S ANOTHER BOOK
AND THAT HELPS TO CREATE THE
ECONOMIC FLOOR THAT IS
NECESSARY. FOR THE ATTRACTION
OF CAPITAL AND EQUITY TO GET
INTO THIS GAME. AND I'LL JUST
CLOSES BY STATING THAT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BEING AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL AND LEADERS.
IS TAKING ACTION LIKE YOU ARE
RIGHT NOW. WE WANT HAVE IT BE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
WITHOUT THE LEADERSHIP OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA THE CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND SPEAKER
RAN DOWN FOR UNDERSTANDING THE
NEED FOR FOCUSING RESOURCES ALL
THIS RHETORIC AND ALL THIS
ACTION. ENSUED ECONOMICS INTO
THIS AREA SO QUITE FRANKLY
BRING THIS AREA OUT OF POVERTY
FOR GOD'S SAKE WE'RE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
HOW IS IT THAT THIS IS NOT
IMMORAL SO WE HAVE A MORAL
BECAUSE- TO USE THE ECONOMICS
OF THIS CRISIS. TO UP WITH THIS
COMMUNITY. AND BRING THEM TO
BEAR TO BE ACTED NANAKULI
COMMITTEE. BY PROVIDING BOTH
ACTIVITY LABOR CAPACITY AS
SECURE AS WELL AS A SOUND
ECONOMIC FUTURE IF YOU DO THAT
WE WILL BE THERE WITH THE
EQUITY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SOTO AND- I KNOW THAT
THAT WE GOT SOME- QUICKER
COMMENTS ON ON THE HAT THAT
YOU'RE WEARING TODAY AND I JUST
WANTED YOU TO BE AWARE THAT- WE
HAD BOTH SOME. PRO AND CON
COMMENTS BUT THAT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND- AND THE
COMMENTS THAT- YOU'VE MADE IN
REGARDS TO THE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CALIFORNIA- YOU'RE GONNA
HATE TIGHT BECAUSE I THINK
THERE MAY BE SOME QUESTIONS I
DON'T KNOW WILL YOU BE AROUND-
UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE A MEETING
IN DOWNTOWN LA AND THEY HAVE
TO. GRAB MY FACE MASK. TAKE MY
DODGER CHAMPIONSHIP RING YEAH
IT'S TOM IT IS REPEATED MIGHT
BE ROLE I GUYS HEARTGARD JOHN
IT WAS VERY LET ME ASK IF
THERE'S ANY IF THERE ARE ANY-
QUESTIONS OF YOU AT THIS POINT
REGARDING YOUR PRESENTATION.
SURE OTHER HABIT THE OTHER THAN
THAT. OF YOUR CAP HAVE A GREAT
TIME AT THE DODGER GAME
TONIGHT. FOR BEING IN PERSON
THANK YOU- I AM THANK YOU HAVE
A GOOD DAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE WITH US. WE
ABSOLUTE WE'RE GOING TO GET
INTO THE WORK FORCE-
DEVELOPMENT DISCUSSION WE'VE
GOT TO INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL BE
PRESENTING HERE. DOCTOR CAROL'S
ABIN RESEARCH DIRECTOR UC
BERKELEY CENTER FOR LABOR
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION. AUTHOR
OF- JUST TRANSITION YOU KNOW
WORK THAT'S- COME OUT RECENTLY.
AND DANIEL MACHINE ASSISTANT
BUSINESS MANAGER IBEW BY SIX
NINE IN THE IMPERIAL SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AREA BOTH WILL HAVE FIVE
TO EIGHT MINUTES. TO PRESENT-
WE'RE MOVING ALONG QUITE WELL
HERE THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR.
YOUR PATIENCE IN PARTICIPATION
SO WE'LL GO WITH DOCTOR CAROL
ZABID AFFRONT YOURS. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMAN GARCIA AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK WITH YOU ALL. IN THIS
REALLY AMAZING OPPORTUNITY- TO
BUILD A SUPPLY CHAIN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. FROM FROM THE
EXTRACTION ALL THE WAY TO
RECYCLING- AND IN A WAY THAT
CAN REALLY BUILD THE PROSPERITY
IMPERIAL VALLEY AND OTHER
PLACES IN CALIFORNIA ASKS TOM
SOTO- VERY ELOQUENTLY- JUST
STATED SO HE'S BACK TO FOLLOW-
BUT- I THINK THAT ASSEMBLY MEN
GARCIA INVITED ME BECAUSE I WAS
THE LEAD AUTHOR OF A- PLAN THAT
JOBS AND CLIMATE ACTION PLAN
FOR TWENTY THIRTY THAT. HE IN
FACT OF WROTE AND REQUESTED- IN
AB THREE NINETY EIGHT A FEW
YEARS AGO AND THE PURPOSE OF
THAT PLAN WAS TO SAY WELL HOW
DO WE REALLY SUPPORT WORKERS IN
THE TRANSITION TO A CARBON
NEUTRAL ECONOMY. AND SO I WANT
TO USE WHAT WE LEARNED IN THAT
PLAN AND IN THAT RESEARCH TOOK
TO RELATE IT HERE- TO THIS.
REALLY LARGE I HATE TO USE THE
WORD INDUSTRIAL PLANNING EFFORT
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T ALWAYS YOU
KNOW THAT TERM DOESN'T ALWAYS
FLY WITH ALL SECTORS OF THE-
YOU KNOW OF OUR COMMUNITY BUT
IT IT REALLY IS AN EFFORT TO
PUT THE WHOLE THING TOGETHER
AND USE GOVERNMENT RESOURCES-
AND GOVERNMENT POLICY TO REALLY
BUILD UP A FULL INDUSTRY THAT-
THAT CAN NOT ONLY HELP MEET OUR
CLIMATE GOALS BUT ALSO HELP.
MEET OUR- EFFORTS TO REALLY
REDUCE THAT HUGE ECONOMIC
INEQUITIES THAT WE SEE AND THAT
ARE PARTICULARLY PREVALENT IN
PLACES LIKE PM IMPERIAL VALLEY
AND THE ISSUE HERE IS THAT AT
EACH STAGE OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO BUILD
WE'RE CREATING JOBS THROUGH
BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENT AND THOSE JOBS SOME
OF THEM ARE PROFESSIONAL AND WE
CAN TAP INTO ARE WONDERFUL YOU
SEE AND STATE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE INFRASTRUCTURE TO BUILD
THE TECHNICAL SKILLS THAT ARE
NEEDED AND A LOT OF THEM ARE.
BLUE COLLAR WORKERS WHO- YOU
KNOW SOMETIMES- GET. GOOD WAGES
AND BENEFITS- BUT IN OUR
ECONOMY ARE OFTEN PART OF ARE
REALLY TERRIBLE TREND OF THE
GROWTH OF LOW WAGE JOBS. AND
BECAUSE THIS IS A BIG. EFFORT
OF PUBLIC PRIVATE AND- YOU KNOW
INTENSE GOVERNMENT INTERVENTION
TO BUILD THE SUPPLY CHAIN WE
CAN INFLUENCE WHETHER OR NOT.
THE A NONPROFESSIONAL JOBS ARE
GOOD JOBS WITH FAMILY
SUPPORTING WAGES AND BENEFITS
YOU KNOW IT REALLY USED TO BE
THAT IN PLACES LIKE IMPERIAL
VALLEY WE TENDED TO SAY ANY JOB
IS BETTER THAN NO JOB- BUT
WE'VE LEARNED THAT LOW WAGE
JOBS ARE PROBLEM FOR FAMILIES
COMMUNITIES AND ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT- SO I THINK. WE SEE
WE DO ALSO HAVE THIS UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN THE TO
EFFORTS OF CREATING A GOOD JOBS
ECONOMY. AND BUILDING A NEW
INDUSTRY THAT IS CLEAN AND
HELPS US MEET OUR THAT THE- IN
ON THE EXISTENTIAL CRISIS THAT
WE'RE FACING WITH CLIMATE AND-
WE HAVE TO DO THAT
INTENTIONALLY- AND- WE HAVE THE
TOOLS NOW TO LOOK AT WHICH
INDUSTRIES ARE GETTING ARE
GENERATING JOBS AND WHETHER OR
NOT WE HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THESE COULD BE
LOW WAGE JOBS AND THEN LOOK AT
THE SPECIFIC TOOLS THAT WE
HAVE. THAT CAN COMPLEMENT THE
OTHER GOVERNMENT POLICIES AND
PROGRAMMES AND MANDATES AND
PERMITTING PROCESSES- THAT CAN
BE USED TO ENTICE THE BETTER
EMPLOYERS TO HOLD THE EMPLOYERS
THAT ARE INVESTING TO THEIR
BEST BEHAVIOR BECAUSE OFTEN
THEY HAVE BETTER BEHAVIOR IN
PLACES LIKE EUROPE THAN THEY
MIGHT IN THE U. S. BECAUSE
EUROPE HOLDS THEM TO BETTER
STANDARDS AND REALLY- BUILD
WHAT WE CALL THE HIGH ROAD AND-
YOU KNOW FROM THE CONSTRUCTION
JOBS WHICH ARE GOING TO BE
REALLY IMPORTANT AND DANNY'S%
GONNA TALK TALK ABOUT- YOU KNOW
BUILDING PROCESSING FACILITIES
BUILDING MARTILLO THERMAL
PLANTS BUILDING MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES BUILDING RECYCLING
FACILITIES. WE HAVE A REALLY S.
AT TRIED AND TRUE METHODS
THROUGH- PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS TO TAPPING INTO ARE
INCREDIBLY VALUABLE
APPRENTICESHIP- SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS THE GOLD
STANDARD OF TRAINING FOR
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS- WE HAVE.
WAYS ENSURE THAT WE TAKE THE
HIGH ROAD IN CONSTRUCTION AND I
I'M I'M NOT GONNA STEAL DANTES
THUNDER BECAUSE I THINK HE WILL
BE VERY ARTICULATE AND TALKING
ABOUT WHAT THE SPECIFIC TOOLS
ARE AND WHAT THEIR- WHAT THE
BENEFITS OF GOING THE HIGH ROAD
ARE IN IMPERIAL VALLEY. IN
ADDITION TO CONSTRUCTION
THERE'S ALSO GONNA BE A LOT OF
OTHER JOBS- AND I THINK WE CAN.
LOOK AT OUR POLICIES AND
PRACTICES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE LABOR STANDARDS THAT
WE DO ENTICE THEM THE BEST
EMPLOYERS AND ENTICE EMPLOYERS
TO BE THEIR BEST- AND- THAT'S
NOT ALWAYS- A COMMON SET OF
KNOWLEDGE OR OR OR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. WITHIN THAT THE
TYPES OF- AGENCIES AND LEADERS
WHO ARE. INVOLVED IN IN LANDING
THE SCHOOL SUPPLY CHAIN- BUT I
THINK OUR LABOR AGENCY REALLY
DOES HAVE AN ENORMOUS
CONTRIBUTION TO MAKE HERE AND
THEY ARE DEVELOPING A TEAM TO
WORK WITH DIFFERENT AGENCIES TO
FIND THE APPROPRIATE LABOR
STANDARDS AND THE APPROPRIATE
SKILL STANDARDS THE APPROPRIATE
UP WAGE STANDARDS THAT CAN HELP
INSURE THAT THESE ARE GOOD JOBS
AND ALSO THAT THERE ARE
PATHWAYS INTO THEM. FOR FOLKS
WHO HAVE BEEN. LEFT OUT OF GOOD
OF THE GOOD JOBS ECONOMY SO I
THINK I WILL- AND THEN A FINAL
POINT IS THAT THE TRAINING HAS
TO FOLLOW THAT YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THERE AGAIN THERE ARE
PROFESSIONAL JOBS THAT. WHERE
ARE YOU UNIVERSITIES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE GOING TO
HAVE A REAL CLEAR ROLE. IN THE
OTHER JOBS THE NONPROFESSIONAL
JOBS TRAINING IS STILL
IMPORTANT BUT IT HAS TO BE
INDUSTRY BASED WE HAVE A
WONDERFUL HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP INITIATIVE THAT
JUST GOT AN EXTRA TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS BUDGET.
WHERE IT FUNDS LABOR MANAGEMENT
PARTNERSHIPS OR OTHER INDUSTRY
LED PARTNERSHIPS WHERE WORKERS
HAVE A REAL VOICE- AND ARE
VALUED IN THAT PARTNERSHIP TO
IN TERMS OF DEVELOPING TRAINING
AND IMPLEMENTING TRAINING AND
BENEFITING FROM TRAINING. SO I
DO THINK WE HAVE MODELS VERY
INNOVATIVE MODELS AND IN THE
STATE FOR ADDRESSING WORKPLACE.
AND INDUSTRY BASED. TRAINING
THAT REALLY CAN UP LIFT THE
pWORKERS HAVE A VOICE AND A
CAREER. AND OUR AND THE WORK
FORCE IS REFLECTIVE OF ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU DOCTOR THANK YOUNG SHOULD
THERE BE SOME QUESTIONS FOR YOU
AS I HAVE ONE YEAR NOTED FROM A
COLLEAGUE WHO IS A PRESENT BUT
WANTED TO DIRECT A QUESTION TO
YOU WHAT WILL HAVE A- MR DANIEL
MACHINE- B. R. LASSEN FINAL
SPEAKER AND THEN WE'LL JUMP
INTO- QUESTIONS. AND COMMENTS-
FOR PRISONERS- THEN FOLLOWED BY
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS THE SECTION
OF THE HEARING ITSELF A DANIEL
IF YOU'RE WITH US- YOU MAY
BEGIN YOU'VE GOT. FIVE TO EIGHT
MINUTES FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU. ALL GOOD AFTERNOON.
YEAH COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ALL
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY.
ARM WAS MENTIONED MY NAME IS
DAN I'M MISSING I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF IMPERIAL COUNTY
BUILDING TRADES. ON CONSOLE AND
ALSO THE ASSISTANT BUSINESS
MANAGER FOR IBEW LOCAL FIVE
SIXTY NINE. I'M DELIVER UNION
REPRESENTS OVER THIRTY SIX
HUNDRED PETITIONS EMPOWER
PROFESSIONALS. INTENDING APRIL
COUNTIES. CHAMBER A DISCUSSION
ON THE PATH TO AN ENORMOUS
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO OUR REGION HAS
PHASE ONE OF THE HIGHEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES IN THE STATE
OF THE DECADES. ARE THE PATHWAY
TO GO THE NUMBER BOSS. BATTERY
SUPPLY CHAIN WORKFORCE THAT
WILL SUPPORT THIS EMERGING AND
LEAVE HIM INDUSTRY IS THE
STATE'S FOR THE FIVE ELECTRICAL
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. I
WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF THE CURRENT I B.
W. THREE SIXTY NINE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM RIGHT
HERE IN OUR REGION. IMPERIAL
COUNTY WE HAVE THE ELECTRICAL
TRAINING INSTITUTE A STATE
CERTIFIED APPRENTICESHIP
FACILITY. THE PARTNER PROGRAM
IS APPROVED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS AND MEETS ALL
CALIFORNIA DIVISION OF
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS AND
REQUIREMENTS AND REQUIREMENTS.
AS WELL OF THE FATAL DEPARTMENT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. I PROMISES
WERE I THINK PROJECTS UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF GENTLEMEN
TRANSIENTS. WILL TEACH THEM THE
ELECTRICAL TRADE. DURING THE
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING THERE
AREN'T ANY COME ALONG WITH ALL
THE BENEFITS. AND THE BILL
CREDITS TOWARDS A PENSION. I
WILL EARLIER SKILL
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING IT'S A
PATHWAY INTO A MIDDLE CLASS
CAREER INDIA ECHO INDUSTRY. I
NEED ONLY IF I SIXTEEN I
MEMBERS LEAVE AND WORK IN THE
VALLEY HAVE CONSTRUCTED OVER
TWO THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE. HOLDER WHEN I
SWALLOW ANY ENERGY STORAGE.
THESE PROJECTS HAVE GENERATED
GOOD PAINTBALL. GOOD PAYING
JOBS AND HAVE PROVIDED SKILL
TRAINING AND BENEFITS IN THE
ECONOMICALLY HARMFUL BLEACHING.
BY THIS YOU CAN SEE THERE IS A
WELL ESTABLISHED LOCAL
ELECTRICAL WORKFORCE IMPERIAL
COUNTY. IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT ALL OTHER TRADES SUCH
AS PLUMBERS AND PIPE FITTERS
CARPENTERS IRONWORKERS
SHEETMETAL AND MANY MORE HAVE
VERY SIMILAR APPRENTICESHIP AND
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS ON
PROGRAMS. WITH THE RIGHT
POLICIES OUR SYSTEM PLACE THE
EMERGING MEDIUM AND- CAN
EQUALLY CREATE NEW HIGH ROAD
JOB OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPERIAL
COUNTY. LOCAL WORKFORCE A NEW
SKILL APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES PARK COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. FROM A LOCAL COMMUNITY
BENEFIT AND WORK FIRST PERSON
PERSPECTIVE WE URGE THESE
SELECT COMMITTEE TO A BACK
PROBLEM INTO THE STATEWIDE
INITIATIVE. OR RELATED
POLICIES. NUMBER ONE REQUIRE
PREVAILING WAGES IN STRONG
WORKFORCE. AND LABOR STANDARDS
THAT CREATE HIGH QUALITY JOBS
FOR LOCAL COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
AND SUPPORT LOCAL STATE
CERTIFIED APPRENTICESHIP
OPPORTUNITIES WE MUST ENSURE
PROPOSAL EIGHT PM AND LOCAL
PROJECTS FOLLOW THE SAME HIGH
ROADS DELPORTE QUICKER AS NOBLE
ENERGY PROJECTS BUILT IN
IMPERIAL COUNTY INCLUDING
PARTIAL PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS POPULIST. NUMBER TO
ENTER ANY EFFORTS IMPERIAL KONG
COMPLEMENT THE ON GOING TO WORK
AT THE SOLVENCY TO PROTECT
PUBLIC. HEALTH AND RESTORE
HABITAT. I DON'T TO THE HEALTH
OF OUR IMPERIAL COUNTY. NUMBER
THREE IN ARE PROJECTS ARE BEING
DONE IN A WAY THAT IS
ENVIRONMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE AND
SAFE FOR WORKERS AND
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES. ALSO
TIES INTO POINT NUMBER ONE
ENSURING PROPER SKILLS IN
TWENTY FOUR CONSTRUCTION.
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
PERSONNEL IS CRITICAL TO HELP
ENSURE FACILITIES ARE RUNNING
SAFELY. AGAIN I CANNOT
EMPHASIZE ENOUGH OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES ON THIS NEW
INDUSTRY. AND I TOLD HIM
INDUSTRY SUPPORT INCLUDING
TRANSPORTATION. AND WHATNOT
WHAT WAS. I SELECT ALSO
VACATION ACCELERATES AND
DEMANDS FOR WHICH STARTS
CONTINUES. WE WILL NEED A WHOLE
LOT OF LITHIUM. THIS MEANS MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TRAINING AND
APPRENTICESHIPS FOR ALL TRAITS.
THANK YOU AGAIN JERRY GARCIA
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALLOW ME
TO THAT TAXIS BECOME THESE VERY
IMPORTANT MATTER. WHAT KIND OF
BUILDING TRADES AND I BEAT
OUTSIDE SIXTY NOW STANDS READY
TO WORK CLOSELY WITH YOU IN
BUILDING OUR- BATTERY
MANUFACTURING RENEWABLE ENERGY
WORKFORCE THANK YOU AGAIN THANK
YOU SIR AND- WE APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE WITH US WE'RE GOING
TO. NOW OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS AND I KNOW THERE WAS
A QUESTION THAT PERHAPS THE
COMMISSIONER DOUGLAS CAN CAN
FLAG OF FROM MY COLLEAGUE- TO
MY RIGHT HERE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN WE- CAN BE ONE SECOND
PLEASE. A QUESTION FROM ONE OF
OUR OLLEAGUES IS ACTUALLY
WATCHING THE HEARING AS WE'RE
DISCUSSING SOME OF THE BE AT
THE PRESENTATIONS TODAY IS- CAN
WE HOW MUCH LITHIUM CAN BE
EXTRACTED OUT OF IMPERIAL
COUNTY. AND HOW LONG WOULD IT
TAKE TO GET IT UP TO SPEED. THE
ESTIMATES OF HOW MUCH LITHIUM
COULD BE EXTRACTED FROM-
IMPERIAL COUNTY ARE. VERY HIGH-
IT COULD BE A- VERY SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF. CALIFORNIA'S
DEMANDS NATIONAL DEMAND EVEN-
INTERNATIONAL DEMANDED AND I'M
GOING TO ALSO DID NOTE BACK TO
OUR STAFF TO GET THE MOST
RECENT NUMBERS BUT THERE HIGH-
IN TERMS OF SCALE UP- I THINK
WHAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW IS
THAT THERE'S A REAL
OPPORTUNITY. RIGHT NOW FOR
CALIFORNIA TO BECOME A PLAYER
IN THE LITHIUM SUPPLY CHAIN
THERE ARE SEVERAL COMPANIES
THAT HAVE MANAGED TO. GET OFF
TAKE AGREEMENTS- FOR LISTENING-
AND- THIS HAS THE POTENTIAL TO-
TO SNOWBALL THE BRING FOR
INVESTMENT BUT WE REALLY DO YOU
KNOW THE INDUSTRY.
REPRESENTATIVES OF WHO WE'VE
BEEN INTERFACING WITH. INDUSTRY
IN PARTICULAR AND THE AUTO
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY THAT
REALLY OF THE SITES THAT WE DO
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD QUICKLY
THIS OPPORTUNITY AS A WINDOW IN
TIME BUT- THE LITHIUM MARKET
IN OTHER PLACES AND SO. WE
REALLY DO NEED TO BE FOCUSED
ON. ON ON THE OPPORTUNITIES AND
INVESTMENT. BRINGING THIS TO
FRUITION NOW. NASA AS A FOLLOW
UP AND BE ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS AROUND EXTRACTION
AND LITHIUM AND THE NEED THAT
WE HAVE FOR PRODUCTION HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
ALSO. INTERTWINED AND THE- IN
IN THE CONVERSATIONS AROUND
ENVIRONMENTALISM IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY ALSO
BEGINNING GAUGE AND I'M CURIOUS
PERSPECTIVES IN TERMS OF WHAT
THOSE CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN
LIGHT. UP I HAVE BEEN LIKE ON
THE GROUND- WITH SOME ENVIRO
GROUPS BECAUSE YES CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO BE SELF RELIANT-
THERE'S LOOKING PRODUCTION ALL
OVER THE WORLD BUT IF WE ARE
TRULY GOING TO LEAD AND FORMER
STATIONS ROTH CLIMATE CHANGE
AND REDUCTION OF FOSSIL FUELS.
THEN WHAT IS THE REALITY OF
THAT FOR OUR STATE AND WHERE DO
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS FALLEN. SO
IT'S A IT'S A BIG QUESTION IS.
LET ME TAKE IT IN AND ARTS AND
THEN IF I IF I MISS A PART
PLEASE PLEASE LET ME KNOW- THE-
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS HAVE
TRADITIONALLY BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF GEOTHERMAL
ENERGY. BECAUSE IT'S A WAY OF
GETTING- OUR OUR HIGH CAPACITY
FACTOR QUITE A LOT OF RENEWABLE
POWER FROM A RELATIVELY LOW.
LAND USE IMPACT IN A RELATIVELY
LOW ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT SO.
ENVIRONMENTALLY ON. GEOTHERMAL
POWER IS IT HAS BEEN SEEN VERY
POSITIVELY AND- IS A REALLY
GOOD OPTION FOR ANY NUMBER OF
REASONS. IT'S ALSO A TECHNOLOGY
THAT HAS. EXISTED IN THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY. FOR A LONG
TIME SO I THINK THERE'S A HIGH
DEGREE OF CAN. UNDERSTANDING
AND ACCEPT OF WHAT THE PROTECT.
IS AS WE MOVE INTO. THE LITHIUM.
RECOVERY COMP. AND SEEN SHOW AS-
AN OBSERVER IN SUPPORT. OF THE-
BLUE RIBBON CAN- THE ABOUT
COMMISSION- THERE ARE IS A NEW.
TO INCREASE CA- UNDER OF WHAT
RECOVERY REALLY ISN'T AND WE'RE
DEFINITELY SEEING THAT- THERE
ARE ANY NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
COMING IN SO THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE CONCERNED THAT. THAT
THE PROPOSAL WOULD BE TO USE
WATER FROM THE SALT SEA RATHER
THAN GEO THERMAL PROVINCE WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN FOR THE SALTON
SEA THERE THAT YOU KNOW THERE
ARE THERE ARE ANY NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS. COMING UP WHERE IT'S
VERY CLEAR THAT FROM A
COMMUNITY OUTREACH PERSPECTIVE
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
ENGAGING WITH THE EQUITY GROUPS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS
YOU KNOW THERE'S A REAL NEED.
TO HELP FOSTER THE LEVEL OF
COMMUNICATION AND INFORMATION
SHARING THAT WILL ENSURE THAT
THE COMMUNITY- IS ENGAGING
UNDERSTANDS WHAT THIS IS ABOUT
AND UNDERSTANDS BENEFITS OF THE
POTENTIAL HERE BUT BUT ALSO HAS
A VOICE IN. HOW IT'S BROUGHT
FORWARD AND SO- THE LITHIUM
VALLEY COMMISSION IS GOING TO
DO- A. AS PUBLIC MEETING IN
COORDINATION WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA'S OFFICE-
COMING UP BUT YOU KNOW THE
COUNTY HAS OFFERED. TO HOST
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC INFORMATION
SESSIONS AND WE DO HAVE.
MEMBERS OF- THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND ALSO.
NATIVE AMERICAN AND OTHER
TRIBES AND- OTHER GROUPS TO WHO
ARE ENGAGED IN THE COMMISSION
AND CAN HELP. WITH THAT MUNICH
CATIONS. I'LL STOP THERE I
DON'T KNOW IF I HIT EVERYTHING
THANK YOU COUNTY FOLLOW UP ON
SOMETHING THAT YOU SAID THIS IS
RAMESH- SO ON THE ONE THING
THAT WE SHOULD ALSO KEEP IN
MIND IS THE SCIENCE OF THE
SEPARATION PROCESSES. AS A BALD
KOMMT CONSIDERABLY. THERE'S A
LOT MORE KNOWN WITHIN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
THE UNIVERSITIES AS WELL AS A
NATIONAL LABS I KNOW COLLEAGUES
OF MINE KID ADOBE IL. ARE
REALLY DOING IT ALL WEIGH
DIFFERENT SEPARATION THAN WHAT
HAPPENED A MOUNTAIN PASS FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN I WAS DOING MY PHD
ON THIS TOPIC. SO THERE IS A
HUGE AMOUNT OF DISCOVERY THAT
CAN LEAD TO A MORE
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY WAY OF
SEPARATING THE TWO. THANK YOU
OUR DOCTOR THANK YOU
COMMISSIONER I THINK YOU KNOW I
I'VE HEARD A COUPLE OF TERMS.
ALONG THE WAY BETWEEN-
EXTRACTIONS. RECOVERY AND
SEPARATION. AND ALL I THINK-
REALLY DEFINING- THIS NEW.
APPROACH THAT EXIST AND- IN
THIS CASE AT THE SALTON SEA-
PERHAPS- APPLICABLES
TERMINOLOGY- TO REGIONS. LIKE
THE ONES THAT ARE ON MY
COLLEAGUES DISTRICT- MR LACKEY
RIGHT ALL I THINK LEADING TO
THE MESSAGE BEING. THAT IT IS
POSSIBLE TO DO THIS IN A MUCH
MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY-
SUSTAINABLE FRIENDLY- MANNER
AND I'LL TELL YOU THAT-
BUILDING OFF OF THE QUESTION
AND THE AND THE RESPONSE. YES
LOCALLY THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
EFFORTS TO IT ENHANCE THE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT PART OF
THIS DISCUSSION UTILIZING THE
COMMISSION THE CDC OVERSEAS BUT
ALSO- THE MEMBERSHIP OF THE
COMMISSION- THE APPOINTED
COMMISSIONERS IS MADE UP OF-
DIVERSE GROUPS OF THE ECONOMY.
I JUST INDUSTRY NOT JUST
SELECTED LEADERS BUT BY A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTATIVES AS WELL AS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND-
ENVIRONMENTAL. GROUPS THAT ARE
TRADITIONALLY WOULD ENGAGE IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS BUT IT IS OUR
JOB TO INCREASE THE LEVEL OF
ENGAGEMENT PARTICIPATION FOR
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN- EXTRACTION
GREW- READ RECOVERY AND
SEPARATION- AND REALLY GET OUR
HANDS AROUND- THIS OPPORTUNITY
IN FRONT OF US OF THE GOOD
QUESTION THANK YOU FOR. FOR
RAISING THAT QUESTION. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS YES CONSUMERS
WITH JUST A FEW GOING DOWN
THROUGH THE LINE AND I'M GLAD
ASSEMBLYMAN LACKEY COME BACK
WHENEVER GUARDS TO BAR ON AND
SALTON SEA. ARE MAKE SURE AND
IT MAY BE A QUESTION FOR KAREN
THAT THERE'S ENOUGH R. AND D.
MONEY FOR DIFFERENT AREAS IN
THE STATE OF LITHIUM IS FOUND.
THAT IT THAT THAT EVERYBODY
GETS THEIR FAIR SHARE WE JUST
DON'T CONCENTRATE NECESSARILY
INSULTS YOU KNOW DON'T TAKE
NOTHING FROM HEADWATERS
DISTRICT. BUT AS A LINES GET
DRAWN THE BORON MINE AND
LACKEYS DISTRICTS ABOUT THREE
MILES WEST OF MY DISTRICT SO IF
THE LINES MOVE JUST A LITTLE
BIT IT MIGHT BE IN MY DISTRICT.
IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS. BUT BUT
JUST KIND OF KEEP THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE THAT WE DON'T JUST
ZERO IN ON ONE SECTOR IN
CALIFORNIA AND MAKE SURE WE
OPEN AT ALL OF. AND THEN THE
DOCTOR RELEASED YOU KNOW ME YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER ON VOTE OF
FIVE TERM PAPERS. THAT TO
PUBLISHED. YES I CAN WE GET
COPIES OF THAT BECAUSE YOU
MENTIONED MENTIONED MOUNTAIN
PASS WHICH IS IN MY DISTRICT
IN. UP I HAVE A LOT OF MINING
IN MY DISTRICT. YES REALLY
INTERESTED IN READING SOME OF
THOSE TERMS- AS WE SAY WE READ
A BOOK OR TWO A DAY SO. IT MORE
READING FOR US. YEAH THANK YOU
T THE END OF. HIS WE WORK
FORWARD. AS THIS COMMITTEE GOES
FORWARD I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
LEGISLATION. EXPANDING UP TO
THE MOBILE OF. FROM FIFTY TO A
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS. MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THE INVESTMENT TO DO
A LOT FOR JUST LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. PERMITTING
PROCESS TAX CREDITS IN
OPPORTUNITY ZONES. AND BUT UP.
YOURSELF EDUARDO THIS COMMITTEE
AND LEGISLATION THAT SURE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH SOME OF
THAT SO WE CAN ALL WORK
TOGETHER PARTNER IN THIS THANK
YOU MISS SMITH AND APPRECIATE
THE- THE COMMENTS OF LOOKING AT
CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE- FOR. THE
PURPOSE OF. AGAIN BEING A
LEADER- IN THIS- AREA OF- CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY. AND MEETING OUR
CLIMATE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES-
BUT. QUESTION MISTER LOOKED AS-
A RESERVE. I DO A QUESTION FOR
DOCTOR- WE SEE THE BUILD OUT
OF- SOLAR- FROM THE BEGINNING
TO THE PRESENT TIME. WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE LESSONS LEARNED IN
TERMS OF- PROGRAMS INCENTIVES
APPROACHES. THAT YOU CAN KIND
OF TOUCH ON THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE APPLICABLES
HERE- THAT WITH THIS-
DISCUSSION ON LITHIUM RECOVERY
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. YEAH
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION BUT
WHEN WE STARTED SON SHOT IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. WE TOOK ALL OF
THE GOVERNMENT APPROACH WHICH
WHICH MEANS WE SAID THAT WE ALL
SORT OF THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES AND WE WANT THEM
TO BE SUCCESSFUL GET THE
BENEFITS OF THE TAX CREATED BY
US BUT- SO IF YOU SOME CHART
WHEN I WAS THERE ARE ALSO PART
OF THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR. TO YOUR PROGRAM.
OXIMETRY THE ORDER OF MANY OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT WITHIN. THE
APPLIED PARTS OF DEAL WEEKS SO
WITH THAT WE HAD FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE YOUR I
WAS THAT BIG TO YOURS I WAS
THAT WE DONE ABOUT. TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWO DIFFERENT FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES. SOME OF THEM
WERE OF THE SCALE OF THE
MILLION DOLLARS R. D.
OPPORTUNITY. AND SOME OF THEM
WENT ALL THE WAY UP TO A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR OPPORTUNITY
WHICH IS VERY MUCH FOCUS ON
MANUFACTURING. MANY OF THEM
HAVE COST SHARE REQUIREMENTS
TYPICALLY. ONE TO ONE OR TWO TO
ONE COST SHARE REQUIREMENTS
BECAUSE WE WANT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. TO HAVE A SKIN IN THE
GAME. AND WE WERE TRYING TO
OVERTLY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT
LEVERAGE WHICH MEANS IF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PUTS A
DOLLAR IN. THAT YOU GET THREE
DOLLARS WORTH OF BENEFIT BY
LEVERAGING NOT ONLY THE PRIVATE
SECTOR BUT IN THE CASE OF
CALIFORNIA I KNOW. KAREN AND
DAVID HOCHSCHILD AND BEFORE
THAT BOB. AND THEY'VE BEEN
FANTASTIC INSTANCE YOU SEE A CO
INVESTING IN MANY THINGS. SO
THAT YOU CAN BIGGER BENEFIT
FROM THE FEDERAL INVESTMENT.
BUT THE UPPER END OF IT I THINK
STEVEN TALK ABOUT IT. WE HAD
THE LOAN GUARANTEE WE STILL
HAVE THE LOAN GUARANTEE
PROGRAM. THE LOAN GUARANTEE
PROGRAM IS IN SOME SENSE OF IN
SIMPLE TERMS. IT'S A DELISTING
PROGRAM FOR VERY RISKY
PROJECTS. ESPECIALLY IN THE
MANUFACTURING OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES. THAT IS PERHAPS
THE MOST DIFFICULT PART IN THE
WHOLE ECOSYSTEM. AND THEREFORE
WE HAD WE I DID A LOT OF
DILIGENCE AND THE LOAN
GUARANTEE PROGRAMS- IN TERMS OF
HELPING COMPANIES- GO FORWARD
WITH THE PROPOSAL'S. SO HOW
DOES SPEC OF. I WANT TO FOCUS
ON. PART I CAN YOU WHAT YOU
WOULD SIX. AND I WILL ALSO TELL
YOU WHAT WE WOULD NOT VERY
SUCCESSFUL. AND DUCK THERE WERE
SOME LESSONS LEARNED THE FIRST
THING WAS TO BE RECOGNIZED
EARLY ON I DO BECAUSE I COMMEND
MY TEAM MEMBER SAID DOE. YES
FOLKS WERE JUST AMAZING- IS
NOT. A BIG PORTION OF THE COST
OF SOLAR WAS THE SOFT COST.
TERMS ARE PEOPLE ARE FOCUSING
ON THE PANEL COSTS AND STUFF
BUT CHINA WAS DOING A LOT OF
THE MANUFACTURING. AND THEY
WERE BRINGING THE COST DOWN BY.
THE WAS A TIME WHERE THE COST
OF. RUNNING THE STORE OF THE
FINANCING THE INTERCONNECT
ISSUES THE INSPECTION ALL OF
THOSE THINGS WERE VERY VERY
EXPENSIVE. SO ONE SUNTRUST DID
WAS REALLY TO PUT A BIG FOCUS
ON THE SO CALLED SOFT COST.
ONCE WE LAUNCHED PROGRAMS-
PEOPLE ATTRIBUTE THIRD PARTY
FINANCING FOR EXAMPLE BACK IN
TWENTY TEN DODD WAS NOT VERY
POPULAR TODAY THAT'S BASICALLY
THE VERY ACCEPTED PROCESS. BY
WHICH YOU CAN DO THESE KINDS OF
FINANCING. HOW DOES ONE
OVERCOME INERTIA INCOMES OF THE
UTILITIES INCOME SO INTEGRATING
SOLAR WHICH IS A VERY BILL
RESOURCE WHAT I'M- INTO THE
NETWORK AND WE WORKED. QUITE A
BIT WITH THE UTILITIES SOME OF
THEM WERE VERY EASY TO WORK
SOMEWHAT A LITTLE BIT. MORE
DIFFICULT. THE ONE THING THAT-
I. YEAH WOULD HAVE LIKED A DONE
MORE. IS MANY. I HAVE TO TELL
YOU ALL. I'M VERY OBSESSED
ABOUT MANUFACTURING WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES WE NEED TO MAKE A
KID IN THIS COUNTRY AND STELLAR
WORK WHITE. AND SO WE HAD
GOTTEN INTO THIS GAME A LITTLE
BIT LATER BECAUSE CHINA HAD
ALREADY MIDDLE PART OF THE
INVESTMENT TODAY 90% OF SOLAR
MANUFACTURING. IS IN CHINA. AND
IS NOW COMMODITIZED SORTS BUT
YOU DIFFICULT FOR A NEW
TECHNOLOGY- THAT'S BASED ON NEW
INVENTIONS TO MAKE IT THERE.
I'M NOT WAS ONE OF THE BIG
LESSONS LEARNED THE ONE THING
THAT I WAS PUSHING FOR PART I
WAS HONORED TO BE DO AT THAT
POINT. YES IF YOU REALLY WANTED
TO THE MANUFACTURING THE
FINANCIAL SECTOR HAS TO BE
INFORMED WAY AHEAD OF RATED
WHAT'S- TYPICALLY WE DON'T DO
THE INNOVATION BIRD WALKS I'LL
GIVE YOU A QUICK NUMBER AND
THEN I'LL FINISH UP. IF YOU
LOOK AT FINANCING IN EQUITY
FINANCING 75% OF THAT WAS
HAPPENING IN THE U. S. IN THE
SOLAR SPACE. WHICH MADE A LOT
OF START UP COMPANIES ALL OF
THOSE GUYS PUT EQUITY
FINANCING. ON DEBT FINANCING
ONLY 11% WASN'T THE U. S. BACK
FINANCING IS WHERE YOU BRING
FACTORIES TO MAKE PRODUCTS AND
SOUGHT. WE WILL NOT DOING THAT
WELL BECAUSE OUR TWO SECTORS IN
THE FINANCIAL SECTOR WERE
DISCONNECTED. AND THEREFORE I
THINK WHEN WE START TO PUT THE
LITHIUM KANEMI TOGETHER PERHAPS
WE SHOULD GET ALL OF THEM INTO
THE SAME ROOM. WHEN WE MAKE ALL
THE DECISIONS SO THAT WE KNOW
HOW THE MANUFACTURER IS GOING
TO HAPPEN. WHEN IT GETS TO
MONETIZE THE MARGIN SO SALUTE-
THEN YOU REALLY NEED THE
SUPPORT OF THE BIG FINANCIAL
SECTORS ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
BILLION FACTORS FOR US. NOT I
THINK WAS A BIG LEARNING
EXPERIENCE WHAT ALSO WAS A
LITTLE BIT TOO LATE. AND WE
WERE CERTAIN GOING FORWARDI
KNOW WE DISCUSSED IT
EXTENSIVELY IN THE TRANSITION
TEAM DISCUSSIONS WE WERE
PUSHING VERY HARD TO HAVE. THE
FINANCIAL SECTOR INVOLVED. UP
FRONT RATHER THAN AFTERWARDS SO
I I'M THAT ENSUED. YOUR JONES.
THANK YOU IT DOES AT THE CAN
GIVE US A CLUE ON. WHAT COULD
DO DE- WHAT WE COULD GIVE. AND
DOUBT KEEPING CERTAIN IN MY-
GOT A QUESTION FOR DAN FITS.
THE LOOKING AT HIS BACKGROUND
YOU KNOW HE HE PREVIOUSLY.
OVERSEEN- THE CALIFORNIA PRICE
OWN- PROGRAMS THAT WERE IN
EXISTENCE AND EARLIER ONE OF
THE COMMENTS WAS MENTIONED.
ABOUT THE EXPANSION OF THE
OPPORTUNITY ZONES- DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS- DIFFERENT- TYPE OF
INCENTIVES BUT NEVER THE LESS-
PUTTING FORWARD- AN OPPORTUNITY
TO STIMULATE THE GROWTH OF
CERTAIN THE ECONOMIES
INDUSTRIES. CAN YOU CAN YOU
JUST TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT- MISTER FITZ GERALD IN
TERMS OF HOW YOU SEE- THAT FIT.
INTO THIS CONVERSATION YOUR
FAMILIARITY WITH PRIOR PROGRAMS
WHY THE NO LONGER EXIST AND
NOW- THIS OPPORTUNITY- WITH THE
OPPORTUNITIES ALMOST TO
PERHAPS- BE UTILIZED AS A TOOL.
YEAH WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
HISTORY THEY'RE GOING TO
SOMEONE NUMBERS L. DOT NET. AND
SO I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
NOW- SO ENTERPRISE AND
OBVIOUSLY THEY THEY WENT AWAY
QUITE SOME TIME AGO AND AS MR
KELLY TALKED ABOUT THE- I THINK
THAT THEY- KNOW THE EVOLUTIONS
THAT OCCUR IN TERMS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES PROGRAMS.
ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL I THINK
YOU KNOW THE SUCCESSOR. WELL
YOU KNOW TODAY WHAT WE SEE IN
THE RETENTION TAX CREDIT I
THINK THOSE THOSE ARE YOU KNOW
I THINK THE EVOLUTION OF THOSE
TAX CREDITS I CERTAINLY COME
ABOUT I THE OPPORTUNITY ZONES
ARE. THANK YOU I THINK THE DAY
THEY FUNCTION MUCH BETTER IN
TERMS OF SOME CONSTITUENTS
AUSTIN'S ODD THAT THAT ARE
PLACED I THINK THE EXPANSION
AND INCUSION OF. LICKING
VALLEY OU'RE LOOKING IN AREAS-
IT CERTAINLY WOULD BE IMPORTANT
FOR THAT BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
COURAGE DOES REGIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE THAT
INSTITUTIONAL INVESTMENT
OBVIOUSLY THE. OPPORTUNITY
ZONES. THEY THEY'RE KIND OF
INTERESTING- I'M NOT YOU KNOW
UPDATE HOMEWORK I DONE WITH THE
IS THAT THEY KIND OF CREATED A
OF A OF A SMALL GOLD RUSH
RICK'S PARENTS THAT I. HERE IN
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THE OPERA.
ARE AREAS WERE WHERE THERE'S AN
ATTEMPT CREATE SOME FUN. I IT
WAS A LITTLE BIT QUICK TO SEND
JOE IF THEY WAS NEXT. FOR THAT
ARE. ON TO THE WITH YOU AND WE
SEE YOU KNOW I. MR START COMING
ON TALKING TO IT. AUSTER STAND.
IN UNDERSTOOD. THAT YOU TO DO
THINGS IN A- INTERNETWORKING
PRACTICE MATTER. SURE THAT
SUPPORTS. AND LYFT. AND SO BY
HAVING. ZONE WHERE. OTHER
MAKING EXTRACTION WITH
MANUFACTURING WORKER. WOULD
CREATE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
CERTAINLY FOR THOSE
INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS AND I
THINK THAT THERE ARE. THERE ARE
SOME POSITIVES FOR
OPPORTUNITIES DOUBTS I ALSO
THINK. YOU KNOW. CERTAINLY
THERE ARE SOME SOME NEGATIVE.
SO ALL RIGHT DON'T THINK THEY
SO I PROJECT TO SERVE SMALL
BUSINESSES PER SE- BEAR THERE
DESIGNED TO SUPPORT LARGE.
ENOUGH WE CAN HAVE. SOME VERY
LARGE BUSINESSES SUCH AS
BERKSHIRE HATHAWAY INVOLVED IN
THIS. IT MAY BE SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE WORK WORKING AT. AND
GET A GREAT ACTOR. THANKS GOOD
I DO A FOR DR CAROL ZABID IT'S
FROM ONE OF OUR OTHER. MEMBERS
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ALTHOUGH NOT PRESENT IT SAID
THIS QUESTION IN QUESTION IS
DOES THE REGION HAVE SUFFICIENT
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENSURE JOB
GROWTH. RESULTING FROM A
LITHIUM MARKET. AND IT'S UP THE
DENTAL BENEFITS- THIS QUESTION
CAME FROM- SOME MEMBER CHAD
MAYES AND SO ADOPTED YET THE
THOUGHTS ON THAT. YOU KNOW I'M
NOT AN EXPERT IN THIS REGION
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT- I THINK
WHAT REALLY IS CRITICAL IS
THERE IS FUNDING AND THERE IS-
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
REALLY BUILD IN THIS. TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS AND AGAIN THAT'S
THE KEY IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT YOU
KNOW PREPARING WORKERS- IN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS IT'S
REALLY ABOUT WORK IN INDUSTRY
PARTNERSHIPS TO UNDERSTAND. THE
NEEDS OF ALL COLORS THE NEEDS
OF WORKERS TOGETHER. TO DEFINE
WHAT THE TRAINING NEEDS AND
USUALLY WITH THAT IF THERE'S
FUNDING THEM COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND ASKING THE OTHER
INSTITUTIONS THAT HIGHER ED
INSTITUTIONS ARE NOT
RESPONDING. RIGHT BUT THEY NEED
TO BE ON THE RESPONSE. TO
POSITION NOT IN THE- YOU KNOW
LEAD AND OF- NEW DEGREE
PROGRAMS AND TELL THOSE ARE
REALLY DEFINED BY THE INDUSTRY
AND OFTEN THEY'LL BE WORKPLACE
BASED PROGRAMS LIKE
APPRENTICESHIP I MEAN THE
BEAUTY OF APPRENTICESHIP. IS
REALLY THAT IT DOES IT EASILY.
EXPANDS TO MEET DEMAND RACKS TO
WHAT WHAT GOES DOWN SO IT'S
REALLY THERE IS A DIRECT AND
COMPLETE CORRELATION BETWEEN
THE JOB AND THE TRAINING. THANK
YOU SO YEAH THANKS THANK YOU I
DO KNOW THAT THE COMMISSION IS-
HOLDING OUT SUB COMMITTEE
GROUPS IN THE WORK FORCE
EDUCATION AREA AND HAS NUMBER
OF INSTITUTIONS ENGAGE FROM SAN
DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY UC
RIVERSIDE TO THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHICH IS A-
POSITIVE THING AND ALIGNED WITH
WHAT YOU'VE JUST SAID I'VE GOT
ONE MORE QUESTION HERE. FOR
STEVEN BOYD AND- AND THEN WE'LL
WRAP THIS UP GOING TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS THE QUESTION IS HOW DO
WE ENSURE ELECTRIC CARS BECOME
ACCESSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE TO
EVERYONE AND- THAT'S KIND OF
THE BACK OF THE MINDS OF A LOT
OF PEOPLE PARTICULARLY IN
DISTRICTS LIKE OURS. WHO HEAR
ABOUT THE ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE JOBS AND THINGS
OF THAT SORT THE QUESTION IS
WILL. HOW MY UNIFORM- WHEELED
VEHICLES AND SO PERHAPS THAT
STEVE WOULD YOU HAVE SOME
THOUGHTS ON THAT. GIVEN THE
BACKGROUND OF YOUR WORK. SURE
SURE WELL AS I MENTIONED- A LOT
OF OUR WORK IS IN THE RESEARCH
PHASE AND IS REALLY FOCUSED ON
LOWERING THE COST OF THESE
ADVANCED VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES
INCLUDING BATTERIES WHICH I
TALKED ABOUT TODAY- WE'RE ALSO
FOCUSED ON REDUCING THE COSTS
FOR ELECTRIC DRIVE SYSTEMS. AND
THE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S REQUIRED FOR THESE
VEHICLES AND SO REALLY SORT OF
ACROSS THE BOARD WERE DOING
RESEARCH THAT DIRECTLY
ADDRESSES THE- SOME OF THE UP
FRONT CAPITAL COSTS THAT WE
KNOW TO BE REAL BARRIERS TO
ADOPTING THESE TECHNOLOGIES.
ALSO MENTIONED- ORI WILL
MENTION THAT- WE'RE WE'RE VERY
FOCUSED ON- BOTH GOT A
COMMUNITY INITIATIVES AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
INITIATIVES THAT CAN BE HELPFUL
IN TERMS OF A TOP SOURCE
TECHNOLOGIES. THANK YOU SIR I'M
GONNA ASK ALL OF THE PANELISTS
WHO ARE WITH US AT THE
COMMISSION DOLLARS HERE DR-
EACH. SHOP IS TO BELIEVE-
BELIEVE- DR CAROL. ZABIT IS
STILL HERE AND DANIEL- AND AT
THE END OF HIS JOKE MAYBE IT
JUST THE GLASS OF THE CLOSING
COMMENTS ON YOUR END BEFORE WE
GET INTO PUBLIC COMMENTS AND
THEN. CLOSING REMARKS OR MAYBE
JUST A QUICK LITTLE WHAT MINUTE
ROUND OF- FINAL THOUGHTS FROM
OUR PANELISTS. COMMISSIONER
DOUGLAS THANK YOU. I THINK
WE'RE ALL WAITING TO SEE WHO
SHOULD GO FIRST. THEY HAVE TWO
THINGS FOR YOU IF I COULD. ONE
IS I GOT BACK THE MORE SPECIFIC
RESPONSE TO THE QUESTION OF HOW
MUCH POTENTIAL IS IN THE SALTON
SEA. THE PRODUCT UNDER THE
SOLVENCY. I SAID A LOT BECAUSE
IN MY MIND I SIMPLIFY IT BUT I
DID GET SOME NUMBERS BACK FROM
OUR STAFF SO. ACCORDING TO
ENROLL THERE IS AN INFERRED
POTENTIAL OF FIFTEEN MILLION
METRIC TONS OF LITHIUM
CARBONTE EQUIVALENT FOR THE
TOTAL RESOURCE. ATTENTIONAL
PRODUCTION IS ESTIMATED AT SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND METRIC TONS OF
LITHIUM CARBONATE EQUIVALENT
PER YEAR WHICH IS EIGHT TIMES
THE TWENTY NINETEEN GLOBAL
PRODUCTION OF LITHIUM. ARE EVEN
IF YOU JUST TAKE THE THREE
COMPANIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY.
PROPOSING LITHIUM IN THE REGION
YOU CAN GET UP TO A NUMBER WHEN
YOU LOOK AT ALL OF THE COMBINED
PROPOSALS YOU GET UP TO A
NUMBER THAT COULD BE. NEARLY
TWICE TWENTY NINETEEN GLOBAL
PRODUCTION SO I YOU KNOW I
DON'T KNOW THAT ANY OF THOSE
NUMBERS ARE PERFECT THEY'RE
CERTAINLY NOT BUT THAT'S WHERE
I STARTED WITH IT'S A LOT. YOU
CAN MAKE A REAL DENT IN. WORLD
WITH THE ON DEMAND IT'S REALLY
UP TO US AND CAN WE GET THE
INDUSTRY. OFF THE GROUND AND
HOW QUICKLY WE STILL AND CAN WE
DO IT IN A WAY THAT IS- IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE COMMUNITY
DIALOGUES IN IN THE- OUT REGION
AND WORK THAT'S CURRENTLY
UNDERWAY AND- IN A WAY THAT IT
RAISES. THE REGION OFTEN
PROVIDES REAL OPPORTUNITIES NOT
ONLY. IN IMPERIAL COUNTY IN THE
SALTON SEA REGION BUT- MORE
BROADLY ACROSS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND- I'M ALSO. AWARE
OF IN TRACKING AND AS I
MENTIONED IS THAT IT. OF THE
ONE FACILITY THE ONE LINE
THAT'S NOW PRODUCING LITHIUM
FROM. TAILINGS AND BORON- YOU
KNOW THE USE THIS IS A IT'S A
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGY IT'S A
DIFFERENT LOCATION BUT IT'S NOT
THAT FAR AND IT ABSOLUTELY. HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO BENEFIT FROM
THIS BROADER LITHIUM. ECO
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE HERE SO I
JUST WANT TO SAY IN CLOSING YOU
KNOW- I'M SPENDING QUITE A BIT
OF TIME AND PRIORITIZING THE
SUFFERS SO IS OUR CHAIR DAVID
HOPE SHIELD AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND- YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE AND WANT
TO BE. AS HELPFUL AS WE CAN AND-
I THINK WITHOUT ALL ALL STOP
AND I JUST APPRECIATE THE
CHANCE TO BE HERE TODAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH SHOP FOR ADDING
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF- VALUE TO
TODAY'S. A HEARING A DOCTOR. SO
LET ME PICK UP WOOD CAL LEFT
OFF YOU KNOW. FAST FORWARD TO
THIRTY YEARS FROM NOW. WE WILL
LOOK BACK AND SAY. BACK IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CLEARLY A
WATERSHED MOMENT. WHETHER YOU
TALK ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE THAT
GAVE THE NOBEL PRIZE YESTERDAY
FOR THE FOLKS WHO PREDICTED ALL
OF THE STUFF ALL WHO. MODELED
EVERYTHING. WE HAVE. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHICH IS
VERY MUCH IN SYNC WITH DOES
THIS PRESIDENT IS VERY
COMMITTED TO COMBATING CROSS.
CLIMATE CHANGE OR WHETHER YOU
LOOK AT JOBS BEING CREATED IN
THIS COUNTRY WE HAVE BEEN ADDED
TO ANYBODY TRACKING JOBS IN
THIS COUNTRY. AND WE NEED TO DO
BUT SO THIRTY YEARS FROM NOW WE
WILL LOOK BACK INTO. WE DID A
FANTASTIC JOB OF CREATING THOSE
LOOKING TO KIND OF BE IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT INCLUDES THE
GEO THERMAL APPROACHES SITTING
TOWARDS OTHER APPROACHES THE
MARKET IS SO BIG GLOBALLY BUT
IT HAS ROOM FOR EVERY APPROACH
THAT WE CAN TAKE OFF. I THINK
WE SHOULD MAKE IT IN THE STATE
INVENTED IN THE STATE AND
SOUTHERN WARD WHITE. THAT'S
WHAT WE SHOULD BE RESPONDING TO
THIRTY YEARS FROM NOW WE SHOULD
NOT BE ST COLLIE WITH MISSED AN
OPTION. SO I HOPE WE GRABBED
THIS. BY THE HORNS AND GO AFTER
IT AND MAKE SOMETHING GREAT
HAPPENED FOR CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU DR WE HEAR THE MESSAGE LOUD
AND CLEAR- STEVEN BOYD. YES
THANK YOU NO FURTHER COMMENTS
FOR ME BUT- IT IS INSPIRING TO
HEAR- THE EXCITEMENT AND- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK
YOU SIR DANIEL OF HIS SHOW. I'M
TOO MANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
OTHER I DO APPRECIATE THAT
HAVING THIS. AT THAT THE SMALL
BUSINESS TOWN CENTRE I THINK
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE LOOK AT
WAYS TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT. ON
GOING YOU KNOW ENTREPRENEURSHIP
AND INNOVATION COME FROM THE
COMMUNITY AND TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE ORPHALI SOME ADDITIONAL
GRANT FUNDS THAT YOU KNOW ****
HAD THE PAST FOR SOME OF THE
CLEANTECHNICA SHE'S THE KALKA
ENERGY COMMISSION. SEATS UP I
THINK THANK SIR TALK TURNS.
YEAH WOULD JUST ECHO THE THIS
IS A TERM. UP AND THAT WE HAVE
TO BE REALLY INTENTIONAL TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE JOBS
PARTICULARLY FOR BLUE COLLAR
WORKERS. ARE GOOD JOBS WE HAVE
THE TOOLS WE HAVE TRIED AND
TRUE. OF POLICY TOOLS THAT CAN
COMPLEMENT- THE OTHER FORMS OF
GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE AND I
THINK WILL MAKE US MORE
COMPETITIVE THERE'S ALWAYS THE
FEAR THAT IT'S GREATER COSTS
BUT- BUT WE CAN. BUILD A BLUE
COLLAR WORKFORCE THAT IS REALLY
WHAT REWARDED FOR THEIR WORK
AND HAS THE SKILLS TO BUILD A
SUSTAINABLE INDUSTRY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND- AT LAST NOT
LEAST- MISTER MACHINE VENDING
MACHINES. AREN'T JUST SOME YOU
KNOW I WANNA THANK ALL OF YOU
AGAIN FOR ALLOWING US TO BE
HERE- BUT AGAIN THIS IS WHAT
MAKES OUR- OUR UNION MOM BETTER
IS THAT. AS TECHNOLOGY CHANGES
AND THE WAY. WE DO OUR WORK
CHANGES. WE'RE ABLE TO CHANGE
WITH THAT WE TOLD ME IN OUR
PLAN IS. ON BATTERIES. ON HOW
TO DO THE. EVEY IDPS CIRCLE K.
AND YOUR MEDICAL TERMS ON TOP
OF WHAT WE DANCE TO. OUR THERE
THE STATE CHANGES ON TECHNOLOGY.
AND WE'RE GONNA AWAY OUR TRAY.
SO WE NEED TO CHANGE CHANGE
COMES. THAT THANK YOU SERRANO
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A CLOSER MY
FROM OUR- ON THE PATH WILL LAST
THE MODERATOR THAT SEE IF ARE
ANY- LINED UP TO SPEAK DURING
PUBLIC- MISTER MISTER
MODERATORS HE THERE. I AM THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND FOR THOSE
OF YOU WISH TO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PLACE. WE
HAVE SEVERAL SEVERAL PEOPLE
WHO'VE INDICATED THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. FIRST GO TO LINE.
SEVEN AM I LYING SEVEN. YOU
LIKE MARC NINE SEVEN YOU'RE ON
I'M- I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED
BECAUSE YOU DO HAVE PEOPLE IN
THE ROOM THAT WANT TO SPEAK BUT
I WOULD LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
MAKE MY COMMENT SINCE I'M ON
THE LINE IF YOU DON'T MIND DID
YOU SAY WE HAVE THREE MINUTES
NOW YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE AND- IF
YOU COULD PLEASE. THREE MINUTES
I'M NOT SURE WHY THERE'S A
DISCREPANCY THE AGENDA SAID
THREE MINUTES YOU HAVE PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM THANK YOU IF I MAY
CLARIFY YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE IF
YOU WANT TO STATE YOUR NAME
AND- ADDRESS FOR THE RECORD.
KNOW WHAT THE CHANGE. I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER THE CHANGES SAID
THREE MINUTES AND THERE'S
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM AND NOW
YOU'RE CUTTING COMMENT TIME SO
YOU. A LITTLE BIT CONFUSING.
YOU'RE A MINUTE YOU HAVE THIRTY
SECONDS TO. MAKE YOUR REMARKS.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS CENSORING
CALIFORNIANS IT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE. BUT I MIGHT AS WELL
JUST GO AHEAD AND SAY. IT'S NOT
A SURPRISE BECAUSE- WHAT NOW GO
TO LINE THAT. LINE SIX OR MINUS
OPEN. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
MANAGER HERE EGGMAN ASSEMBLY
MAN AND I- WE REMEMBER IF I
HAVE RETURN THE TAXPAYER- TO
SET UP A PAYMENT AS THE WORLD'S
IN HOME EMISSION AND COMING
CHINA OUR SEVENTH. AND THEY'RE
BUILDING MORE. WELL THEY'RE
THEY'RE BUILDING THREE HAD MORE
FACTORIES THE WORLD. THEY NO
PLANS ON THE NOT THAT. CLICKING
BATTERY. OUR ENVIRONMENTAL. WE
ALL. I'M QUITE THE BIRD AFTER
FOUR MORE TO ALREADY
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT MORE
CARBON DIOXIDE. IT DOES SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN USES SEVEN
STARTLING HER. FORTY YOU AGE
YOU QUICKLY. MY TO FLY FROM
HEATHROW TO REMEMBER YOUR HAVE
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY OF FUEL
RELEASE ABOUT THE THREE TO AS
THE- STILL THERE FOR ABOUT THE
IN. WHY ARE WE ONLY PLAYED. AS
GIVE ALL MORE HARMFUL THE- TWO.
NOW GETTING BACK. TO ARE WE
GOING TO PUT THEM LINE FOR. ARE
WE SUPPOSED TO DISPOSE OF THE
SAFELY OR REFI. WHAT YOUR
BATTERIES ARE KNOWN MATT ME
FOCUS MORE THEO TO INTO THE AIR.
MORE THAN CONVENTIONAL CALL.
AND HOWARD MEMBERS SO FAR THE
NEW BATTERY YOU YOUR VEHICLE
YOU HAVE SECONDS. FOR NEXT WEEK
I WILL NOW GO TO LINE NINE LINE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY FIRST
QUESTION IS WHERE WILL ALL THE
GAS CARS GO NUMBER TWO IS. WHY
YOU'RE COMMUNICATING ABOUT
MANUFACTURING THAT THING
CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU KNOW THAT'S
NOT THE TRUTH YOU'RE GOING TO
TAKE THEIR AND LET CHINA
MANUFACTURED THESE BATTERIES
AUSTRALIA'S RIGHT NOW THE
NUMBER ONE CHILLY FALL THEN IN
ARGENTINA BUT HERE LET ME
EXPLAIN SO THIS GREEN FAIRY
TALE OF YOURS ON ELECTRIC CARS.
WERE IN OTHER COUNTRIES THEY
ARE LITERALLY SITTING IN VACANT
LOT BECAUSE WHILE THESE
BATTERIES DRINK HOT INTO THE
GROUND. SO HERE IS THE FOCUS ON
THE EMISSIONS AND THE LITHIUM
THAT NEW GOLD RUSH FOR
CALIFORNIA THAT YOU GUYS ARE IN
STEALING AND TRYING TO PUSH TO
ART THAT IS AN EMPIRE MENTAL
DAMAGE AND CHEMICAL
CONTAMINATION. YOU SHOULD BE
ASHAMED AMPLATS ALSO FORMAL
AFFECT THE FIELD BILL YEARS
WHICH CREATE FIRES IF YOU'RE
NOT FULLY AWARE OF THAT I NEED
TO DOCTORS ON THERE SHOULD KNOW
THAT AND THERMAL HAZARDS ALSO.
THANK YOU FROM. EIGHT NEXT- WE
WILL NOW GO TO LINE SIX. M. I.
OUT THAT MIGHT BE YOU HELLO.
THAT IS. PLEASE GO AHEAD. M.
WHAT WHAT WHAT IS IT MAY ON THE
IT IS YOU YES MA'AM GIVE ONE
MINUTE. AFTER THIS ENTIRE
WRITTEN. NEXT PEOPLE NOW GO TO
THE NEXT SPEAKER AND PARDON ME
JUST A MOMENT FOR THE NEXT
SPEAKER. LINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ENTERTAIN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. ALL RIGHT MAYBE WE
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT CHAIR JUST
A MOMENT PLEASE WE DO APOLOGIZE
FOR THE DELAY. AND WE HAVE ONE
MORE PERSON WHO'S SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST ANOTHER
MOMENT THANK YOU. WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO TO LINE TWELVE.THANK YOU MODERATOR- THANK YOU-
CHAIRMAN GRASSLEY AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JOURNEY
CANNOT. BE HALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL I WON'T REPEAT
WHAT- THAT REPRESENTATIVE- FROM
THE LOCAL BUDGET COUNCIL SAID
BUT JUST TO REITERATE- OUR
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE ESPECIALLY IN
THE IMPERIAL VALLEY- ARE READY
AND WILLING AND ABLE ALREADY-
FILLING OUT THE WORKFORCE NEEDS
OF THE LOCAL AREA AND THEIR-
COMPARED TO RAMP UP FOR THIS
INDUSTRY AS WELL. WANT THAT
THEY ALREADY ARE AS DANIEL
MENTIONED- I AM VERY
APPRECIATIVE AT FIVE ON BEHALF
OF THE PEOPLE THE TRADES THAT.
THE YEAR ENDING HELD AND WE ARE
FORGET- MARK STONE ABOUT THE
WORKERS GREAT IN A BILL THIS
INDUSTRY- WORKING ABOUT THIS ON
THE FRONT END. DOESN'T ALWAYS
HAPPEN UNFORTUNATELY BUT WE'RE
APPRECIATIVE THAT AND WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE WORKERS
PLACES THE NEEDS ARE- CAPERTON
CENTER- DURING THIS PROCESS I
THINK CITING- INDUSTRY THAT IS-
NOT. PART OF OUR- AND WE HOPE
ABOUT THE PART OF THE BILL THAT
IS STREET COURT THANKS SO MUCH
AGAIN. THANK YOU. FOR YOUR ONE
TELL TO LAW FIFTY BECAUSE LINE
FIFTEEN LINE IS NOW OPEN. ALL
RIGHT. THANK GOD WE MIGHT BE
DONE MISTER MODERATOR. YEAH YES
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF MY ASK OF
MY COLLEAGUES APPEAR TO HAVE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS. I NO.
WHERE WORK ON SCHEDULE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIR FOR. DOING
THIS BUT I'M- I WANT PEOPLE TO
REALIZE SAID THAT THE LITHIUM
MINUS SALTON SEA IS ALREADY
COMING THROUGH THE THERMAL
WATER THAT'S BEING PUMPED OUT.
IT IS NOT NECESSARY TO BE IN A
WHOLE NEW OPEN MINE PIT.
MINIMAL GO TO LECTURES HE'S NOT
GOING TO BE ELECTRICITY
VEHICLES INFRASTRUCTURE
OVERNIGHT BUT IF WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE BATTERIES FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES WE MIGHT AS WELL
MANUFACTURER CALIFORNIA WITH
THANK YOU. FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU SELECCI. YEAH FIRST
OF ALL LIKE TO THINK OF. THE
CHAIR AND THE SPEAKER FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE PART OF THIS
GREAT PARTNERSHIP THAT WE HAVE
TO LOOK FORWARD TO. THERE'S
CLEARLY A WORLDWIDE DEMAND FOR
THIS PRODUCT CALLED AT THE END.
AND- ONE OF THE MORE EXCITING
PIECES IS THE FACT THAT THERE'S
SUCH A RICH COLLECTION THE TO
BAR MENTALLY FRIENDLY. AND
AVAILABLE. IN MY HOME TOWN THAT
I GREW UP IN MY AND- MY FIRST
UNION JOB IT WAS. A PRIVILEGE.
TO ACTUALLY OF WORK IN THAT.
THAT INDUSTRY AND NOW TO
ACTUALLY SEE THAT IS A
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE GREEN FUTURE
OF THIS WORLD MUCH LESS THE
STATE. IS IT'S NOT REALLY
SURPRISING BUT IT'S A VERY VERY
EXCITING OPPORTUNITY THAT- AND
THE SALTON SEA OPPORTUNITY IS
ALSO ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY THAT
I'M VERY VERY THANKFUL TO
PARTNER WITH I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANYTHING I CAN DO TO ADVOCATE.
AND TO- FURTHER THIS GREAT
BECAUSE THAT OF THE WORLD'S
ASKING FOR SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
THIS GREAT PRIVILEGE THANK YOU
TO BOTH OF YOU AND OUR
COLLEAGUE THAT. IS CARILLO. WAS
HERE AND I THINK I MAY HAVE-
SKIP THE PEACE HERE YOUR ANYONE
IS IN THE- IN THE AUDIENCE THAT
WANTS TO GIVE A PUBLIC COMMENTS
PLEASE COME FORWARD BEFORE WE
CLOSE- THE HEARING IN HERE
RIGHT WHERE WE'RE STILL ON ON
ON TIME AND I APPRECIATE. ALL
THE SPEAKERS- STAYING ON POINT
AND- RESPECT INSIDE EVERYONE'S
TIME PLEASE YOUR YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AFFILIATED. AND
YOUR COMMENTS YEAH ONE MINUTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SELENA
I'M FROM SUTTER COUNTY- I JUST
WANT TO TOUCH ALONG THE LINES
OF WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER SNIFFER
THING. OF A WHOLE LOT OF THE
SPEAKING TODAY THE
PRESENTATIONS WERE ON A LOCAL
LEVEL AS OPPOSED TO CALIFORNIA
AS A WHOLE- SO I'M ACTUALLY
LIVE IN A FARMING COMMUNITY- WE
DEPEND A LOT ON. GAS POWERED-
EQUIPMENT FOR FARM WORK AND-
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE LYCIUM CAN
BE CATASTROPHIC TO WATER
SOURCES. ALSO I DIDN'T HEAR A
LOT ABOUTTHE HEARD IN BETWEEN
THUS FOR SOURCING JOBS FOR
COMMUNITY. BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
END OF THE PROJECT SO FROM THE
NINETEEN WHAT THAT INTEL'S AS
FAR AS THE ENVIRONMENT ALSO AT
THE END OF THE LINE WHAT
HAPPENS AS FAR AS DISPOSAL-
TAKING CARE NAY ENVIRONMENTALLY
ABOUT THE EFFECTS OF THE
LOOKING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS THOSE ARE GOOD
COMMENTS AND I'LL ASK OUR TEAM
AND THE COMMISSIONERS I THINK
THERE IS A LOT OF INTERESTS AND
US HAVING. A CONVERSATION IN
TERMS OF WHAT HAPPENS AT THE
END OF THE LIFE OF THE BATTERY
AND IN ORDER FOR US TO REALLY
TAKE THIS ON COMPREHENSIVELY.
THAT IS A CONVERSATION THAT WE
NEED TO DIVE INTO AS WELL AND-
AND THIS IS. CLEARLY A STATE
WIDE OPPORTUNITY GIVEN THE-
OTHER. RESOURCES AVAILABLE
MINERALS AVAILABLE OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE- THAT WE TOO WOULD
LIKE TO ENGAGE INTO THAT
DISCUSSION AND AS YOU HEARD
COMMISSIONER DOUGLAS FROM THE
CC THERE FAMILIAR. WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE- AND SO WE APPRECIATE
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO KIND OF.
BRING THAT ALL TOGETHER- SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS TO
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO MAKE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS THAT- HERE WITH
US TODAY. CASINO ONE IT. SHOWS
THAT THIS EARLIER BUT I KNOW
THAT THE COPS DRAWS ON THE
NUMBER. YES AT TIM KELLER I
WANT TO DRESS A COUPLE THINGS
IN ONE YEAR THAT OU CATION.
ABSOLUTE YOU KNOW SENDING A
STATE UNIVERSITY AS A TWO
HUNDRED. ACRE ON CAMPUS IN
RALEIGH. AND IS WORKING ONALL.
PROGRAMS CURRENTLY THEY HAVE
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE
FEET SO. THE CAMPUS IN DOLLARS
ACTUALLY LARGER IN THE CAMPUS
AND- IN SAN DIEGO SO WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR GROWING.
DAHLE DALY COLLEGE ONE OF THE
FEW. COLLEGES THAT'S BEEN
GROWING AND SO WE'RE WE'RE VERY
COMMITTED. TO THE WORK FORCE
AND- EDUCATING OUR LOCAL
WORKFORCE BUT- YOU KNOW THE OLD
KJRH SOLVENCY IS ONLY SIXTY
MILES FROM CONTROL BALLOT. AND
AND SO EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES
ALSO THERE I MENTIONED- STUDIES
UNIVERSITY IN MEXICO ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION PEOPLE JUST SOUTH
OF THE BORDER. A WILLING TO
CROSS THE BORDER AND WORK IN
AND WE SEND A LOT OF STUDENTS
TO MEXICO TO BE TRAINED IN. A
LOT OF OUR EMPLOYEES ESPECIALLY
ENGINEERING COME FROM MEXICO.
SO WE'RE VERY UNIQUE SITUATION
I THINK SOME OF THE QUESTIONS.
THAT PEOPLE HAVE I REALLY
INVITE YOU TO- YOUR CHECK UP TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT NOT
EVERYTHING'S THE SAME WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MONEY WITH
THEM IN CARROLL COUNTY IT'S NOT
LIKE MINING LITHIUM IN CHILE.
ARE WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MANUFACTURING IMPERIAL COUNTY
IT'S NOT LIKE MANUFACTURING AND
ALEC- ONE THING WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT WAS HOUSING. YOU KNOW WE
ARE GROWING COMMUNITY AND- ONE
OF THE REASONS THAT WE ARE
LOCATION THAT'S THAT'S VERY
SUITABLE FOR- MANUFACTURING IS
BECAUSE THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS. THE LOWEST POSSIBLE
IT JUST TO BE IN THE STATE THE
LOWEST COST WATER IN THE STATE
AND SOME OF THE LOWEST COST
HOUSING THE STATE. AND THE
LOWEST COST PLAN. AND WE HAVE
AN ANOMALY WHICH JUST HAPPENS
TO HAVE LOOKING. SO YOU PUT ALL
THIS TOGETHER IT'S- YOU KNOW
IT'S A PERFECT STORM. WE NEED
TO DO IT RIGHT AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE PLANTED OUT
CORRECTLY WHEN YOU DO A QUICK
AND THE REASON WHY. TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IT'S HOW
LONG IT'S GOING TO TAKE AT THE
MINIMUM. GET THIS INDUSTRY
GOING WE DON'T WANT TO PASS US
BY. BECAUSE IF WE DON'T IF WE
CAN'T DO IT LOCALLY IT'LL BE
DONE SOMEPLACE ELSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SEE COUNTY I WAS TOLD
YOU WERE GOING TO BE HERE FOR-
QUESTIONS BUT I'M GLAD THAT
YOU. CHIMED IN WITH YOUR
CLOSING REMARKS- WE WILL
CONCLUDE THIS HEARING YEAH I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE PALACE
PRESENTERS- THOSE WHO HAVE
SPOKEN PUBLIC COMMENTS AND MY
COLLEAGUES FOR ATTENDING. I
THINK YOU TOO LEAN MODEL FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER WITH ALL
OF. OUR OTHER PARTS. THIS MEANS
GUARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU YEP.